at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by viori
clothing spelled v-u-o-r-i
viori i've been wearing viori at least
one
item per day for the last few months and
you can use it for everything it's
performance apparel
but it can be used for working out it
can be used for
going out to dinner at least in my case
i feel very comfortable with it
super comfortable super stylish and i
just want to read
something that one of my employees said
she is an athlete
she is quite technical although she
would never say that i asked her if she
had ever
used or heard of vyori and this was her
response i do love their stuff been
using them for about a year i think i
found them at rei first for my partner
t-shirts that are super soft but somehow
last as he's hard on stuff and then i
got into the super soft cotton yoga
pants and jogger
sweatpants i live in them and they too
have lasted they're stylish enough i can
wear them out and about the material is
just super soft and durable
i just got their clementine running
shorts for summer and love them the
brand seems pretty popular constantly
sold out
in closing and i'm abbreviating here but
in closing with the exception of when i
need technical outdoor gear they're the
only brand i've bought in the last year
or so for yoga
running loungewear that lasts and that i
think look good
also i like the discrete logo
so that gives you some idea that was not
intended for the sponsor read
that was just her response via text
viori again spelled v-u-o-r-i
is designed for maximum comfort and
versatility you can wear it running you
can wear their stuff
training doing yoga lounging weekend
errands or
in my case again going out to dinner it
really doesn't matter what you're doing
their clothing is so comfortable and
looks so good and it's it's
non-offensive that you don't have a huge
brand logo on your face you'll just want
to be in them all the time and my
girlfriend and i have been wearing them
for the last few months they're men's
core short kore
the most comfortable lined athletic
short is your one short for every sport
i've been using it for kettlebell swings
for
runs you name it the banks short this is
their go to land
to see short is the ultimate in
versatility it's made from recycled
plastic bottles and what i'm wearing
right now which
i had to pick one to recommend to folks
out there or at least to men out there
is the ponto performance
pant and you'll find these at the link
i'm going to give you guys you can check
out what i'm talking about but i'm
wearing them right now
they're thin performance sweatpants but
that doesn't do them justice so you
gotta check it out ponto ponto
performance pant
for you ladies the women's performance
jogger is the softest jogger you'll ever
own
viori isn't just an investment your
clothing it's an investment in your
happiness and
for you my dear listeners they're
offering 20 off your first purchase
so get yourself some of the most
comfortable and versatile clothing on
the planet
it's super popular a lot of my friends
have now noticed are wearing this
and so am i viori clothing dot com
forward slash tim that's
v u o r i clothing dot com
slash tim not only will you receive 20
off your first purchase
but you'll also enjoy free shipping on
any us orders over 75 dollars
and free returns so check it out
theoryclothing.com
tim that's v-u-o-r-i clothing dot com
slash tim
and discover the versatility of the ore
clothing
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is inevitably
athletic greens
i view it as my all-in-one nutritional
insurance i recommended it in 2010
in the four-hour body and i did not get
paid to do so i've used it ever since
developed from a complex blend of 75
vitamins minerals and whole foods source
ingredients
athletic greens is a greens powder
engineered to help fill the nutritional
gaps in your diet
so i always try to do things through
whole foods but this covers my bases
right now athletic greens is offering
you their vitamin d3 k2 liquid formula
free with your first purchase
two vital nutrients for a strong immune
system and strong bones
so simply visit athleticgreens.com tim
to claim this special offer today and
receive the free d3k2 bundle with your
first purchase
that's up to a one year supply of
vitamin d as added value when you try
their delicious and comprehensive
all-in-one daily greens product
again that's athleticgreens.com tim
why hello boys and girls ladies and
germs whether you're here across the
pond in the pond or otherwise this is
tim ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show what i
just said will make sense in a moment
it is my job on every episode to
deconstruct
world-class performers to tease out the
favorite books the habits
routines forms of journaling whatever it
might be
that you can test and apply in your own
lives my guest today i've wanted to have
on for a very long time
his name is richard kosh koch
richard is an entrepreneur investor
former strategy consultant and author of
several books on business and ideas
including four books
on how to apply the 80 20 principle in
all walks of life
he also has a wonderful british accent
which is why
i talked about across the pond his
investments
because he's not just a theoretician
he's a practitioner his investments have
grown at 22 percent
compounded annually over 37 years that's
a long time
try that with a small number and see
what happens richard's investments have
included
filofax plymouth gin belgo betfair
which is the world's largest betting
exchange we talk about this one quite a
bit
fanduel and auto one he has worked for
the boston consulting group
and was a partner at bain and co that's
bannon company before leaving to start
lek with jim lawrence
and ian evans which expanded from three
to three hundred and fifty professionals
during the six years richard was there
in 1997 the 80 20 principle the book
reinterpreted the pareto rule extending
the observation that most results come
from a small minority of causes
which was well known in business into
personal life happiness
success and more the book substantially
updated in 2017 has sold more than a
million copies
i have bought many of those myself and
given copies away
it's been translated into roughly 40
languages and become a business classic
it was named by gq magazine as one of
the top
25 business books of all time his new
book published on august
13 2020 is unreasonable success and how
to achieve it
in it richard charts a new map of
success which he says can propel anyone
to new heights of accomplishment
high success he says does not require
genius consistency
all-around ability a safe pair of hands
or even basic competence which is
reassuring
but it does require the nine key
attitudes and strategies
he has identified we dig into all of
this and more
in this conversation it's important to
note i had a great time doing this
that's not important but the following
is important
that we talk about a lot in the world
of investing and consulting because i
want to give
you all a lens into his thinking
so rather than listening to someone say
negotiating is important i would prefer
to dig
into real world examples of what they
have done
so you can learn how to fish
metaphorically speaking as opposed to
being given a fish in the form of some
type of
fortune cookie parable or something like
that so we get into a lot of concrete
details in investing and consulting and
those are lenses through which you can
look at
many many areas in your own life whether
it's personal or business so i just want
to explain
that and i think that's enough preamble
we get into a lot we get into the art of
gambling 80 20 principle happiness
islands
achieving unreasonable success ball
aching insights
journaling walt disney and lots more
without further ado
please meet richard kosh you can find
him on twitter at richard kosh8020
and online richard kosh.net
richard welcome to the show i'm so
thrilled to have you
it is in some respects decades overdue
and we were just chatting before
clicking record
could you please get us started with
wines and spirits it's a great pleasure
to be
uh talking to you tim thank you very
much for all your generosity
in giving me quotes to put on books and
things like that that's very much
appreciated
um i'm not sure that this is a great
place to start but i was just thinking
that you had reinvented the talk show
and when i was 17
and i had a first job in windsor england
as a van driver for a firm of wines and
spirit merchants they were called lovey
bonds
and they were probably about the most
old-fashioned wine and spirit retailer
you could possibly imagine
and one of the things which they did was
deliver wine and spirits
to quite a distinguished bunch of people
actually i used to drive into windsor
castle and give the brigadier his gin
and so on and so forth
but one of the other people that i used
to visit was michael parkinson
and michael parkinson as you know was
very successful sports writer and
broadcaster
who then branched out into doing chat
shows and some of the stuff which he did
was marvelous i saw a clip
the other day of him talking to david
bowie and it was fantastic they were
really enjoying themselves
and they were moving very smartly from
point to point and that made me think
about you because i think you reinvented
the chat show on podcast and it's just
amazing
so anyway that was that's my non-story
to start with
well give me time to disappoint and i
appreciate
the kind words and i should also say for
people listening
those people who perhaps uh
have have read the various policies on
my website will
will note or received one in my response
via email will know that i say i don't
give
quotes for books i don't do forwards i
don't do
and i have a very long list of do not
do's the reason
that i've made an exception is that and
if anyone else fits this bill feel free
to reach out because i know it's going
to be approximately zero
if you if you've written a book like
uh several of your books that have
traveled with me
for more than 10 years from place to
place
that sit on my shelves face out as a
reminder
feel free to reach out but that is going
to be a very small number
indeed and perhaps we could start
this isn't exactly the beginning so to
speak but with
the bodleian library and if you could
explain what that is
and take us into context from there
i think that would be helpful the
bodleian library is a fantastically
beautiful
building in oxford very close to the
college that i was at
and i used to sit in there in the stacks
and look out of the window whenever i
could but the great thing about it was
it had almost any book that you could
possibly imagine and one
day i decided that i wanted to read a
book which i had read about
called the course of economic theory in
but it was in french
written by our old friend vilfredo
pareto
and it was published in um low cern
in i think 1896 and 97
and i have no idea at all tim
why i wanted to read this book because
it wasn't part of my coursework or
anything like that
but that was a book in which i
discovered the 80 20 principle
and he didn't call it the 80 20
principle as you know
but nevertheless he had all these
algebraic equations
which showed the wealth distribution in
england
in the 17th century 18th century 19th
century
and also in italy france switzerland
other countries
over those periods of time and what he
found was that there was the same
pattern of distribution of um
wealth against the population and
a a remarkably similar chart could be
drawn
from the algebra for any of those
countries or any time
uh in order to show what proportion of
wealth was owned and of course it was
a very small number of people or
proportion of people
who actually owned most of the wealth or
earned most of the money
so you might say well that's very arcane
and it's not particularly interesting
but i instantly thought i can use this
i can use this to cheat in my
examinations
without actually choosing and so
what i did was to say well i do know
that i'm going to have to write
11 papers three hours long each
at the end of my time in oxford the
oxford degree is entirely
determined by the final examinations
there's no
assessment current or there are no
previous examinations at all
so it's a very very important thing but
i had noted that on sample papers
there was something like 50 questions or
whatever and it's impossible to imagine
that i could actually research or do
work on 50
questions times 11. so i thought
well maybe if this 80 20 principle
applies
there will be some questions which are
asked much more frequently
and lo and behold i got the papers for
the history exams
for the last 20 years and it was
absolutely true there was always a
question about the french revolution
there was usually a question about the
russian revolution there was always a
question about the
origins of the causes of the first world
war and so on and so forth
so i said to myself well you know i
don't need to
study very extensively you could write
the answers to three or four questions
it was your choice during three hours so
what i said was i will research
six subjects no more
uh for each paper and
uh i will be word perfect i will have
very obscure quotes
i will use foreign languages that i
don't actually understand
absolutely word perfect and if i do that
i don't have to do much work
and i will get a top degree and
lo and behold that is exactly what
happened and then i thought to myself
afterwards
gosh this man pareto was quite under
something wasn't he
so that was my introduction to the 80 20
principle
and uh yeah perhaps i've never looked
back in some senses
you know what is well to me so funny
about that in part is that i did
something very similar
i just was not aware of pareto at this
point but when i was
doing my undergrad i about halfway
through
began asking teachers to give them some
degree of
sort of plausible deniability because i
was hesitant to ask outright what is
going to be on the exam because they're
not supposed to answer such a question
but i would ask
teachers or i would say rather i know i
need to study everything
that we've covered for the exam but if
there are any particular areas you think
i should focus on
would you mind telling me and they were
very forthcoming
so it ended up having a very similar
effect although i definitely
was pleased that in most cases not
everything
hinged on final exams i think i probably
would have been crushed under the
sort of the psychological intimidation
of that type of sink or swim
setup yeah i was quite nervous in my
sense but i i found a solution to that
at least in the afternoons
was that after the morning paper i would
go down the pub
and have a couple of pints of beer
and i found that car my nose and it was
notable that i got better
results in the afternoon than i did in
the morning
well that could be in one of your one of
your next books if you haven't covered
academic hygiene and preparation
now if we're looking at formative
periods
let's just say high school college
university however we want to
label it i'm looking at notes as i do
in these types of conversations from an
interview you did with boing boing
a long time ago an outlet that that i
know very well and
one of the questions posed was what
advice would you give to a smart kid
who's now in high school
and you can feel free to fact check this
incorrect but the answer i'm just going
to read
briefly and then i have a follow-up
discover what you're best at doing and
enjoy
that is different from what all of your
peers are doing and it requires
relatively little effort from you then
put huge effort into honing that skill
so that it becomes
monstrously greater than anyone else's
keep demanding
that each year you make your peculiar
talent more peculiar and much more
potent
use the skill to make the world a more
interesting place don't care about
making money if you have a fantastically
different and useful skill
everything else you want will follow so
i have two questions
accurate or not accurate quote secondly
what is your peculiar talent and how did
you discover it
well it's totally accurate and it's very
easy to give advice and perhaps less
easy to
originate the advice or at least to
exemplify the advice
i was always very very interested in
history because
it enabled me to develop a certain skill
in analysis with
non-quantitative analysis i'm absolutely
hopeless
at numbers but in terms of understanding
structures in terms of understanding
trends in terms of
really getting to grips with what might
have happened
that other people had not noticed then
that's what i did and you know i came up
with some
pretty wacky ideas uh
during um during my time studying
history
but i thought that they were plausible
and the examiners must have thought so
too i mean for example
it seemed to me that hitler had been
copied pretty much what lenin and stalin
had done
so of course hitler was great and
anti-communist and they were great
anti-nazis
but he actually had followed lenin's
policy for example
of a one-party state which no one before
lenin had really done
and of death camps for dissidents and
enemies of the regime again no one had
really done that certainly not on such a
ruthless scale
as uh lenin and later stalin did so it
was
my theory that hitler had based his
policy
on the bolsheviks and it's that's just a
little example
i'm not absolutely sure that's true but
it's plausible
and it's sort of trying to winkle out
um things that might be true which are
interesting and important
but which no one else has spotted that's
what i try and do that's what i enjoy
doing
so you mentioned hopeless with numbers
now
or maybe i injected the hopeless but you
you uh were
very self-deprecating with respect to
numbers
and numeracy and yet people would look
at
your track record of investing as an
example
and ask how can that possibly be
the case so again in my notes
i have betfair here which i would love
for you to explain
but it adds that you couldn't use their
website now
please explain okay well
the the way of reconciling those two
apparently different things i do have a
very good track record thank god
i've been very lucky or um very
fortunate
at least in my investments but it's not
based on
being an analyst in the conventional
sense um
i got fired from the boston consulting
group because i was no good at doing
financial and market analysis despite
the fact that i was quite good at doing
some other things which they didn't
value very much
it is true that i'm not particularly
numerate
but i believe that's a skill which is
you know readily available from other
people
and as far as betfair is concerned
i base my investment as indeed all my
investments are based on the star
principle
which was something that the boston
consulting group themselves had invented
uh way back in the 1960s and this is the
old chart of the dogs
stars question marks and cash cows so
i never make an investment unless the
business is
is a star business or has the potential
to be a star business
and bcg's definition my definition of a
star business
is the market leader in a niche a
defensible niche
where you can protect it against other
people other other competitors
and a high market growth rate bcg said
more than 10
i've really tried to aim at more than 30
and the thing about betfair was that
a friend of mine in 2001
came along and said we've started this
betting company and i'm
a gambler i like gambling and we
think it's completely different from
anything else because it's not a
bookmaker and i said well what do you
mean and he said well
a bookmaker is someone who makes a book
and basically offers odds to punters
gamblers who might want to
bet on it but betfair doesn't do that
what it does is
it started an electronic market which
enables people to either act as the
bookmaker
or to act as a punter so you can go on
to the site
and you can see posted up there the odds
other people will give and the odds for
the punters are vastly better
because there's no bookmakers profit now
i said it can't be true because
betfair has to make some money how do
they make money what's their business
model
he said well they have a very small
commission which they take and they only
take that
on winning bets and so i said well that
sounds like a fantastic idea so what's
the problem
and he said well do you want the real
truth
and so i said yeah of course i want
anthony of course i want the real truth
what
what's the problem he said well
no venture capitalist no professional
financial firm would invest in this
company
when they first had their round they
started about six months previous to
this
and uh and he said then there was you
know from their point of view a very
good reason for that which was
none of the managers in the business had
had any experience i said oh you mean
they didn't have experience in the
industry he said
no no they don't have experience in the
industry well
one of them used to be a professional
gambler but that's not experience which
uh venture capitalists would recognize
as being applicable
uh he said no they never run anything
and i said to me so answer you're
telling me that i should put money
into a business that has
people running it they've never run
anything else he said well one of them
used to be a financial
debt person at morgan stanley and he was
making
you know he was trading loans and and
doing that sort of stuff
and he said you know trading loans is
not a million miles away from running a
betting exchange
but you know the truth was that they
they really
were all sports enthusiasts or gambling
enthusiasts
and none of them had had any experience
of management which explained why it was
only friends and family who had been
able to invest in
what would be willing to invest in this
particular company
so i said to anthony well what's the
attraction he said it's a star business
richard and
anthony had worked for me in lek and
also in a company was set up after ldk
called strategy ventures
and so he knew that i knew that the way
to make money
in investing in small businesses was to
actually
invest in something which could be or
was a star business
well you know even though it was tiny
and even though it was losing money
it was clear that betfair was indeed a
star
business and why was it clear because no
one else was doing what they were doing
their business model was completely
different
their cost structure was completely
different their customers were
completely different
all of their customers were
sophisticated and quite large
not all of them but most of them were
sophisticated and quite
large gamblers and so you know there
they didn't compete with lad brooks or
the other
um corals the toads the other british
bookmakers
and in fact they didn't compete with
anybody because there was there was
nobody there's actually
another firm set up originally in san
francisco called flutter
it had a slightly different business
model so it had no competition had
infinite relative market share so i said
well that's fantastic
so he said well let me give you the
website and
uh you can go on and see how how it
works well unfortunately i couldn't
because i didn't know how to work the
website
and i went along and talked to the
people and just tried to make sure that
it was indeed a star business and that
i thought that you know it could
actually
get some professional management later
on and so
after an hour i decided to invest
1.5 million pounds in that business
and they were quite shocked by that they
said well
are you sure and i explained to them
what a star business was and how it was
wonderful and how they should be very
pleased to be having a star business
and all the rest of it but they were
quite taken aback at that
and they had been trying to raise money
again from institutions that all said no
and the mates that they had to put the
money in originally
you know didn't want to put more money
in particularly that he used that money
much more quickly than expected
the reason i used the money much more
quickly than expected was that the
growth was fantastic it was a tiny tiny
tiny business
but it was growing at 40 percent 50 even
60
a month and you know i said well you
know
the other thing which i believe in the
part from the star principle is compound
growth rate
and so i you know i looked at their
financial projections and i thought they
were incredibly conservative considered
considering the market growth rate
and so i invested and i went on to the
board and
about four years later the chaps had
a um an away day at which i
said how wonderful star businesses were
and so on and so forth
and then i said and actually last week
i decided it was time that i actually
learned how to use
the website that you have and they all
felt about laughing
they thought i was joking and i said no
i did i think it's great
great website and they said to me well
how could you possibly have invested in
the business without
sort of going onto the website and i
said well it's a star business and they
said to me that i mean i think i went
down in their estimation quite
considerably
as a result of that mission and of
course now i use the website
most days but uh and i think it's i
think it's a wonderful website i've sold
my shares so i'm not advertising the
company or anything like that
but i ended up making about 100 million
pounds profit out of
out of that investment so that's the
power of the star principle so
so how can someone who's not numerate
make money
out of what is generally a highly
numerate industry well the answer tim
is very simple i believe in principles
and i believe in the star principle
and it works i'm the only investor in
the world that does this
and i think i'm the only investor of the
world of my scale but doesn't employ
anyone
and that does it on the basis of
probably about a day a week of work
i do use my personal assistants to do
some of the work i do use
contacts for special particular jobs but
you know i don't have any staff
and you know when i told people this
they say well
you know your your portfolio is x that's
i'm i'm absolutely unbelievable
i said well you know i've only got one
question uh when i
invest in a business is it a star
business or could it be a star business
and once i've invested i want to retain
it as a star business or make it
more dominant and the only question is
how do you do that
and so life is very simple
i'm laughing because we could have five
hours and i'm gonna run out of time
before i run out of questions
so let's bookmark a few things we're
gonna come back to knowledge versus
principles okay so we'll bookmark that
i want to just make it clear at least
from wikipedia
and wikipedia of course is subject to
debate but
often and accurate and betfair is
is described as the world's largest
online betting exchange
just for for those who are looking for
some type of perspective and are not
familiar with the company
and you had mentioned gambling and
liking
gambling i want to dig into that because
it strikes me
that you may enjoy gambling but you're
also very good at placing
bets and those are not necessarily the
same thing
if we think about the psychological
dynamics
drivers and criteria involved and i want
to
explain also to people listening that
investing is a
wonderful metaphor for and framework for
exploring
principles that apply elsewhere thinking
processes that apply elsewhere or
perhaps even everywhere
so my question for you is very specific
1.5 million
how did you decide on that bet sizing
uh that was all the money i had
holy [ __ ] wow okay so you just pushed in
all your chips yeah then all my liquid
assets you know and this is quite
typical for me i mean
i i want to be fooling you well
something i'll talk about later which is
one of the things which is quite absurd
about me
is that i actually don't have very much
money to spend and i don't really mind
that
i tend to when i'm in london for example
in normal circumstances i would take
public transport i would go on a bus or
a tube i would cycle if i possibly could
but i wouldn't take a taxi or even an
uber
unless it was absolutely you know i was
desperately short of time and i don't
believe in being desperately short of
time i always make sure i have plenty of
time
because i don't want to be rushed and
because i can always use the time to
think or whatever
so how do i just decide on the bet sizes
you know it's just a matter of what i
have available if i think it's a good
bet
i hasten to i don't make money out of my
horse racing gambling
that is purely an entertainment and i
don't place particularly large bets
relative to
my net worth either and you know if i
can go
for 18 months without having to put any
more money in my account i'm very happy
it's a different kind of bet i mean
gambling i think is
gambling conventional gambling whether
it's poker or it's at the
casino or it's uh horse racing or it's
betting on tennis or
or baseball or football or anything like
that you know i
i think there are people who make money
at it but they usually either have some
inside information or they are
incredibly skilled
at judging probabilities and they often
have you know even research i know
someone who had
50 employees tracking football in order
to
see whether the odds on particular
football matches
were right or not and he would take
positions and he made a lot of money out
of that
consistently every year but you know
someone like me who doesn't know a lot
about football
knows nothing about football not doesn't
know a great deal about horse racing
but you know is it a certain
disadvantage i just i
i i have a particular method which i use
which is based on
uh looking not where the horse came in
the race but on the time
relative to other times and all that is
calculated on the racing post website
it's called something called top speed
and whenever i make a lot of money
in horse racing it's because top speed
has shown me a horse which is not far
away from the favorite
but might be at odds of thirty to one or
in one case it was even three hundred
and thirty
one that's unusual but
betting on companies is fantastic
because if you understand how important
relative market share is
and if you understand whether or not a
company is able to segment itself
and therefore have a defensible position
in a particular segment like betfair
then it's absolutely fantastic because
you can
you know you can basically invest and
know that you might lose your money but
overall you're going to
do very well out of that and you know i
have very rarely lost money
on star businesses the cases where i've
lost money
is where i thought something might
become a star business and it wasn't
does that answer your question it does
and i have a whole handful more
to follow up so you wrote an entire book
on this the star principle 2008
it that was published in 2008 work and
investing in
star businesses that was the focus when
you
say segment itself businesses that can
segment itself
and you mentioned betfair what what does
segmenting itself
mean it means that it it defines the
market in a way that
nobody else has done or
that very few people do and therefore
that it's possible to become a market
leader in it so
betfair is a very good example of that
it's a betting exchange
which is an electronic market where
people can post bets on
either side buy or sell it doesn't take
principal positions
as bookmakers do so it's um
once it's overheads are covered it can't
lose money
and it competes against other betting
exchanges not against the big bookmakers
because anyone who's a big gambler isn't
going to go
to ladbrokes or corals or the tote or
paddy power or any of those
conventional bookmakers because they
know that the bookmaker typically takes
out about ten percent
on each event and betfair takes
out maybe two percent but that's only
half the time if you win
half a time and lose half the time so
it's one percent plays
10 percent and therefore it means that
the customer profile is completely
different
and the way that the cost structure
operates is completely different
so it's a separate business segment
because
it's not competing with conventional
betting firms so it means that the
company has to do something differently
it either has to be have a price
advantage
and therefore cost advantage in the way
that betfair
does or it has to offer something which
is so attractive
that people will pay even if it's the
same price they will actually go to
go there so you know the three things
that you want to do if you want to
what i call proposition simplify are you
have to have something which is very
useful
you have to have something which is easy
to use
and preferably you want something which
is aesthetically pleasing which
gratifies you as a joy
to use and if you think about any of the
apple devices then they created their
own segments with the ipod and the ipad
and the iphone and other devices
because it was different from
conventional competition even the mac
really didn't compete head to head with
ibm
and anything where you can get a big
price premium for example 30
plus as apple's been able to do on all
of its devices
at least at the start you have something
which is a separate segment
because it's not competing against the
low-cost
competitor and if you are going to be a
low-cost competitor
you want to be low-cost in a segment
which is different from
the other segments because otherwise the
existing large
companies will eat you for breakfast you
are unconventional in many different
respects
and i'd like to ask you a personal
question you can feel free
to decline to answer this question but
i'm
very curious as to what your
investment portfolio looks like what
principles
govern its composition because you had
mentioned that you're
quite happy to have small amounts of
liquid assets you know cash available so
what does your portfolio look like to
the extent that you're comfortable
discussing it and what what are the
principles that govern its composition
well
it's uh pretty much an illustration of
the 8020 principle but more so
i suppose my most valuable single i've
got about 40 assets
companies in which i've invested and the
most valuable company
in the portfolio constitutes about the
half the total value
and another one constitutes about a
quarter of the total value
and so in a way that also simplifies my
life because if i
if i take care of those two particular
assets and know that they're going to do
well or think that they're going to do
well then i can be relatively relaxed
i'm quite happy to increase my share
in companies once i know or think i know
and i'm not infallible
that they are going to be successful so
for example the company
that i is my largest single investment i
started off with a relatively modest
investment that might have had about two
percent of the company
and i'm now up to 60 percent of the
company and
basically what i'm doing is buying my
shares from the existing shareholders
whenever there is an opportunity to make
an offer for shares which is
you know when i've got some money so
that's the principle i don't have any
rules on industry i don't care what
industry it's in
i don't really care very much what the
management is like because the
management doesn't perform
management will eventually get replaced
i don't really care where it is as long
as it's not
well as long as it's in europe because i
think i understand european markets
i won't invest in the u.s because
competition is too great and also
because
i don't like the irs and also i don't
know anything about
american investment so it's basically
a european portfolio industry irrelevant
and i don't care about concentration
in fact i rather like concentration
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by bowl
and branch long time listeners will
recognize the name ball
and branch b-o-l-l and branch i've been
sleeping on them every night for the
last six months as one example
when i decided to overhaul my life for
better sleep to change all sorts of
things i landed on bowl and branch for
linens
they are incredible right out of the box
and you feel the difference immediately
they are the softest
and most comfortable pure organic cotton
sheets available they are
thousand dollar quality for a fraction
of the price starting at just 160
dollars
bowlin branch helps my body sleep better
at night and i only learned recently
many reasons for why they should also
help my mind and conscience
sleep better at night in india as an
example the average life expectancy of a
cotton farmer is 35 years old because of
potent pesticides on one hand
and supplier debt leading to preventable
suicides on another
to mitigate all of this bowl and branch
have become the first fair trade
certified manufacturer of linens
and they've committed to using 100
organic cotton because it makes a better
life for the people who grow it
in addition to a superior product this
also saves about 90 percent
of the water used in conventional
farming methods so
sleep better at night check out bowling
branch you'll feel the quality in the
craftsmanship
the moment you open the box and you can
sleep on them for a month absolutely
risk-free
right now you can get 50 off any sheet
set at bowlandbranch.com with promo code
timtim that's one word tim tim
and the url is spelled bowlin branch
b-o-l-l
n branch dot com promo code tim tim for
fifty dollars off
bowlin branch dot com promo code tim tim
restrictions
may apply see bowlin branch dot com for
details
remember bull and branch dot com promo
code
tim tim
let's go back to getting fired
just just to warm up the conversation so
i
what happened after you were fired and
could you actually tell us more about
the the day that you were fired what was
the conversation
what was that experience like and then
what happened after you were fired
well it was a slow firing and in fact it
was a very gentle firing
bcg like mckinsey mckinsey invented the
phrase up or
out and at mckinsey they would say that
after three years
you would be assessed and if you were
really good at their business
you would get promoted and if you
weren't you'd be asked to leave but they
would do it in a very very nice way
because they were sort of dividing the
sheep and the goats the
the sheep were the people who were good
enough for mckinsey and
the goats were people who are good
enough to be mckinsey clients so that
was their
their philosophy and they were terribly
nice to the people but in fact it was
kind of like
it was a form of i don't know it was a
form of sort of
uh psychological one-upmanship because
the
the people who left generally weren't as
bright
as the other people it wasn't that they
could do things that the
mckinsey people couldn't do it was that
they weren't as bright in terms of the
strategy of a business and analysis and
so on and so forth
so that worked extremely well well bcg
did not have quite
as rigid a formula as
mckinsey but they did have this policy
that if after three or four years
you had not been made from a consultant
into a manager a consultant was a
typical
entry level for someone who'd been to
business school uh
you would um you know you'd be pretty
much
an anomaly would be the way that they
would probably put it and and therefore
you know you might start thinking about
what you wanted to do
and so i had a number of those
conversations with people
uh but i said to him look you're dead
wrong
this was me this is me and my arrogant
youth and maybe i haven't got rid of
the arrogance altogether the the i said
look
i'm no good at analysis but i can charm
with clients
i can talk to the clients um i'm quite
articulate
and i can understand what the issues are
the strategic issues and i can relate
those to the clients so
you know i might not be very good at
being a consultant i might not even be
very good at being a manager but why
don't you make me a vice president
because i could actually do rather well
and they would chortle they would say
richard you know we have to have a
hierarchy
and i said well you know x adrian for
example
adrian's now a vice president we all
know that he was a pretty good
consultant
but he wasn't a terribly good manager
because he he couldn't command the
analysis
and that's the heart of you know what
bcg does
and so he had to rely on other people to
do it but now he's a vice president he's
selling a lot of business
very successfully and helping clients so
you know i'm like adrian basically and
they would against chortle a bit
but eventually a guy called very nice
guy called phil hume who's
later started the computer center and
made quite a lot of money out of
computer center
uh he sat me down and said richard you
know
you are running out of road a bit and i
said well look i got a fantastic
assessment from roy barbie the other day
you know he said how much the clients
love he said yes rich
we know that but but basically you can't
do what
what is really our power alley so so
um maybe you sort of think about looking
around
and i came out from that meeting
thinking is he right
is he right about this or am i right and
i thought to myself well
maybe he's right so i actually then very
quickly
went to other consulting firms to
mckinsey and to bail and company
to see whether yeah i say something
richard just for a second
that is for people who don't have any
context on management consulting
when you say mckinsey when you talk
about boston consulting group when you
talk about bain in company
just as a point of reference for folks
who may not be familiar with this
industry
when uh when i was studying at princeton
there were exactly two
industries that recruited heavily you
had the investment banks
you had goldman sachs and a handful like
that and then you had
what were considered the elite of the
elite of management consulting and that
included
mckinsey bcg in other words boston
consulting group
bain and company and so on so these are
the most prestigious names in the world
of
of management or strategy consulting i
just wanted to to add that
as a bit of background yeah thank you
sorry everyone knows and they don't i
mean it's a very
when i was doing it it was a very
obscure industry
uh and now it's less obscure but it's
still it's still pretty pretty obscure
anyway i i went to mckinsey they said no
you're a bright guy but we don't think
you should be doing this management
consulting stuff because you want to
make decisions
rather than advise and
i said yep that's probably true bone and
company i'll come back to in a second
i then said well maybe i should be a
headhunter and i was actually approached
by firm headhunters
some of whom knew me personally and so i
went off to see egon zender
in zurich with a view to becoming an
egon zender was the leading at that time
probably still is the leading european
headhunter
just a footnote there for people head
hunting means
recruiting right very high level and
taking very large amounts of money
from the club so anyway
i talked to egon centre and and he
offered me a job on the spot and i
very nearly accepted on the spot but
when i sort of examined my heart i
came back to the conclusion that i
thought bcg was wrong
and you know i might not suit bcg but i
thought you know maybe i can get a job
in another consulting firm
there happened to be another individual
who had left
the boston consulting group and joined
bain and company
a guy who rejoiced in the name of floyd
bradley iii
and you might tell he was an american
very very nice guy
quite a smart guy anyway so he i
arranged to have a drink with him and
said
you know i'm not too happy with bcg i
don't think they're moving me on fast
enough
um how about bailing company do you
think that
that they would uh do you think that
they would be interesting so yes they're
always looking for people that
find it quite difficult to recruit
people at this stage
um and so i said fine i'll go along talk
to him so i went along and talked to the
head of the london office and he said
we'll send you off
to boston now this was very interesting
for me
uh it was my one chance basically to
stay in the industry that i wanted to
stay in
the only problem with bonin company was
it had a reputation
for being an extremely hierarchical
strict controlled almost um
mystical outfit where you had to do what
you were told
uh whereas bcg actually was a pretty
freewheeling entrepreneurial sort of
firm reflecting the difference in
character between the guy who had
started
bcg bruce henderson and the guy who runs
iran rather uh bailing company i should
say that he's dead now so i can't be
sued for libel or slander or whatever it
is neither can you
although i have the utmost respect for
billboard as i'll come on and say it in
a second
so they sent me off to boston so there i
was i
i had a you know four o'clock
appointment with to see bill bain
in the afternoons i got off the plane
got a cab to
their off boss boston office and um
turned up at the desk and said i'm here
to see mr bain
at four o'clock and the woman sort of
looked a bit confused numerous and
basically
what had happened was that the someone
in the london office had not told the
boston people
although they'd given me a ticket to go
and see him given me
an appointment time apparently it had
not somehow not got into the agenda of
mr bain
so they said come back following morning
so i went back following morning
and um there i was you know i went
through the offices they were
the offices were quite remarkable they
were beautiful offices but
the associates the the consultants and
the researchers were all hunched
together
it was you know it was not quite a
sweatshop it was a very nice sweatshop
but you could see that they were
either expanding very fast or very tight
on the rental
cost and then i went into bill bone's
office and
it was palatial you know it was stuff
full of basketball and baseball
trophies and insignia and paraphernalia
of all sorts and he was sitting behind
this large desk
and got up very graciously to meet me
and said do you want anything to drink i
said no i don't want
anything thank you and then he started
talking to me
well it was very fortunate for me
because i didn't
find out until afterwards but it turned
out that bill bone was a historian that
was his undergraduate degree and in fact
he had
spent a year doing postgraduate research
which eventually gave up because he
thought it was terribly boring
and because he got offered a better job
as the development director of
vanderbilt university
but during the course of that interview
bill bain
said something and i thought well i want
to ask him a question but he was in full
flood
so i let him carry on talking until
probably about 20 minutes afterwards and
then i went back to it and said
you know if i got it right mr bain you
said earlier
such and such and such and such and i
want to ask you a question about that
blah blah blah
and he said you're incredibly unusual
and i said what
and he said well you're a very good
listener and not many people are good
listeners
and i wasn't aware that i was a good
listener and maybe it was just i was so
desperate to get a job
that actually i was actually listening
but i was also very curious about the
business because
right at the start when i had joined bcg
i thought what a wonderful industry this
is it requires no working capital
and uh basically they charge
huge fees they don't pay people a hell
of a lot of money eventually they give
them bonuses which is where the working
capital comes from the difference
between
the standard pay and the markup which is
some of which is eventually rebated to
the
professionals involved and it's
expanding very very fast and they've got
this great model
called the growth share matrix because
it's got market growth on one axis
and it's got the relative market share
on the other so they call it gross share
matrix but it's more popularly known as
the boston box
and it's this thing which has cash cows
dogs question marks and stars the the
one thing i just wanted to say
also is an observation of friends who
have come out of mckinsey
is that it seems that two by two
matrices are very popular
for organizing thought yes and in fact
beast uh mckinsey went one better they
developed an imitation of the boston box
which was a three by three matrix
but as always economy is everything and
it wasn't as good
and it isn't as good in my humble
opinion anyway
but the end of the story is that bill
was quite taken with me and i was quite
surprised and he said i want you to come
and talk
to ralph willard one of the other
founders of bail and company and ralph
was a very jolly chap and we got on very
well and so on and so forth so they they
actually offered me a job
and then i said to them well ralph said
how much do you want to be paid
and i said well i'm earning such and
such a boston consulting group but
obviously if i'm going to take a step
like this i want a 50
increase 50 percent that's ridiculous
and i said well you know maybe you can
just make me an advance for
for joining and not consolidate it into
the salary
but you know at that stage i was feeling
confident that they wanted me so i sort
of raised the stakes a little bit
despite the fact that
at the beginning of the day i was
totally desperate and if they'd offered
me a job
after an hour i wouldn't have cared what
they were going to pay
but anyway they did eventually pay me
quite a large amount of money
to join and at the same time i then went
back to bcg
and said you know i think you're making
a mistake
but if you want me to leave you know
i've got all this money which i'm due in
a few months time as a bonus and the
rest
please can i have that and to my
surprise they said yes okay
i mean they were so desperate to get rid
of me that they agreed
so i made quite a bit of money from bcg
and from boeing company
so it was quite apart from the fact that
the previous two or three years have
been
very very miserable and i was i i
redoubled my efforts to succeed at bcg i
worked 80 hours a week
i got fat in the face from eating fast
food at night
you know i basically neglected my
personal relationship i stopped
exercising it was
a complete disaster and you know if
if i was to give advice to anybody who's
in a similar situation or even a less
desperate situation
i would see if say if you're not
succeeding in a job
give up and go somewhere else where you
know your talents can be better
appreciated or
your talents are more suited to what
that firm does so i just
tim i just could not admit failure this
was the thing you know
i just to me personal success was
absolutely essential to my happiness
and it has affected my self-image and
all rest and i could not believe
that these very intelligent people at
bcg couldn't see
the things that i could do and you know
it would have been far better for me to
say well you know they just have a
different business model
you know analysis quantitative heavy
duty stuff is there is their bag
and uh you know it's not something i can
do particularly well
and so please give up and stop and and
you know
decide whether you want to be in the
industry or decide you know if you if
you do want to be in the industry go to
a competitor
so the long and short of that story
is it worked out extremely well in the
end but it was absolutely
balls aching very unpleasant
[Laughter]
i wanted my pound of flesh at the end of
that we've gone through what did bain
and company
appreciate about you or utilize in you
that was not utilized or appreciated at
bcg
oh it was it's very simple to answer
that because i've always been
interested in what i call the theology
of business and by that i mean the
business model that a particular firm
has and bcg and boehner company were
very very
interesting to me and this goes back to
your first question about what am i good
at doing
i actually did analyze in my mind not
quantitatively
the business model that bcg had and the
business model that bonin company had
and they used the same concepts they
were all used
both using the the growth share matrix
of boston box etc which incidentally
bilbane had helped to originate
so it wasn't really plagiarism and
indeed bcg had put the stuff out there
in the public domain
so it wasn't you know they weren't doing
anything underhand but they were using
all bcg's concepts
but the firms were completely different
and let me try and describe how they
were
very different bcg as i said before was
a very
sort of decentralized company
and the vice presidents who are in
charge of particular clients
were sort of almost autonomous profit
centers
bruce absolutely believed in the market
he was a he was a red toothed
capitalist you know he really read in
tooth and claw he really believed in
competition
and so on and so forth so much so that
that he divided his firm
uh at one stage and this is quite
interesting this is before my time
but he divided the firm into three
different parts
and his view was that if one of those
firms had developed a slightly different
way of doing things
it or if they were successful for any
particular reason then the other firms
could learn from that
and the market would clear as he was
fond of saying
um and what happened was that he put
bill bain whom he had hired
from vanderbilt university where he was
the development director and met bill
bain because he was had the begging bowl
out
uh to as an alumnus of of vanderbilt
bruce as an anonymous and he asked bruce
um will you give money to vanderbilt
university and bruce said no
but come to boston and we'll talk about
giving you a job so
you know that was kind of like the back
story from that point of view but bcg
was very very decentralized
and even each individual consultant
was or all the professionals were
actually profit centers they were
rewarded at the end of the year not on
how well they'd done not on their team
performance
not on um anything really but their
what he called their billability which
was a number of hours
that they had actually built and
incidentally i was probably one of the
most billable people because i i was
willing to work very long hours um and
because initially at least anyway people
wanted me on their teams
and if they didn't want me um i could
even sell my own work so
so i had to be included in the people
who were
on on that but it was very very
decentralized bain and company on the
other hand
was a very very controlled
and i actually called it stalinist later
on um
organization where it radiated out from
bill bill
did all the thinking initially and then
the trusted vice presidents who included
mitt romney who was a great guy
a guy i've got tremendous admiration for
um
and uh four or five other vice
presidents
and the the formula in bonin company was
very
very um tight and
unforgiving um which is that they
generated
all of their business from a
relationship with the chief executive
or the head of the company sometimes a
president
or the chairman of the company but
usually the chief executive or
maybe they were president and chief
executive and they would not work
for anybody who was not the top dog in
the organization
so they wouldn't work for you know the
head of europe or they wouldn't work for
the head of manufacturing or
marketing or any other function
but they had a spiel which they gave to
the chief executive company which was mr
chief executive
we want you to be very successful
because if you're very successful we
will be very successful
we've got this funny little stuff called
strategy which really works and we can
explain it to you
but basically you should think of it as
a wonderful formula
a kind of like a secret source for
increasing the market value of your
company
profits and the market value and
if we do the work with your company your
share price will double within the first
year or so
or the first two years anyway and it
will continue doubling every few years
because we have got a way of making a
firm much more valuable and we can
describe that
but it relies upon you being willing
to accept us as equal partners
and again this was very very different
from the whole of
the rest of the industry which was in a
way
salesman for hire or cabs for hire that
you know
consultants would do anything as long as
they got their daily rate
and and so on and so forth they didn't
really care too much about which firm
they were working for
they would work for competitors and so
forth bonin companies said we will only
work for one company
in an industry or later they refined
that to a competitive system
which was sort of slightly more
sophisticated way of saying industry
and therefore you know we won't work for
your competitors
you won't hire our competitors and
so therefore you'd be giving a monopoly
on strategy consulting
or any other form of consulting really
to bailing company if you decided to
hire them
and the way it's incredibly smart yeah
it's very smart and the way in which
they got clients tim
was that they would they had no website
but that wasn't unusual at the time
they had no business cards they had no
uh marketing literature
you know and the only way and they were
very secretive
the only way in which they got business
was by personal recommendation
of one chief executive to another chief
executive
and then within that firm once the
client had been signed on you know
guinness or dun and bradstreet or baxter
travel
or whoever it was uh they
would then have almost a military
operation where within each client
organization
someone from boning company would be
assigned to
work alongside or with nominally for
you know the head of manufacturing or
the head of a particular product area or
however the firm
organized itself and they would
make sure that they understood what that
person
was thinking they would help them by
gathering this very valuable information
which barely the company did very very
well
about competitors and customers and
costs of the
competitors and that they would you know
develop a relationship
i couldn't believe it when i was told by
spain and company when i joined you know
take the head of manufacturing out to
dinner
and discuss things with i thought yeah
last thing i want to do is have dinner
with the head of manufacturing who's a
very boring man
and you know it was all part of the job
and it was incredibly effective because
you know whereas at bcg they they would
go away for six months and they'd come
back and give a presentation which was
dazzling
but then people in the audience of the
managers
might were free to disagree with what
was recommended
and cast often did cast doubt on the
credibility
of bcg as a result of that rightly or
wrongly usually wrongly
in bailing company everything had to be
pre-wired
so all the work was specified from the
top down
but it was validated from the bottom up
so that once you've done a piece of work
you then had to show it
to the relatively low level manager and
make sure that they agreed with it
and if they disagreed they could only
disagree about data they couldn't agree
disagree about concepts because we were
the kings of concepts we knew relative
market share was important and we could
explain why
we weren't unreasonable but nonetheless
when it eventually got to the chief
executive
and then later to the board it had all
been pre-wired which meant that
everyone had agreed to everything and
therefore there was no disagreement
and the only discussion which there'd be
at the end of the presentation
was about what they always used to call
next steps
well let me tell you what next steps
were next steps were
this is how we're going to make our next
million dollars by consulting to you on
this issue
but of course it was justified because
bailing company was a fantastic machine
for getting consensus in organizations
and
getting consensus about some very
radical strategies which might include
getting out of half the businesses that
they were in selling them
or in some way hiving them off
or closing them down if they were cash
negative and no one would buy them
and then making acquisitions to to
strengthen existing businesses or even
to go into new areas
where boiling company would do all the
investigation because particularly if it
was outside the industry that
the company knew about of course they
hadn't they had no idea
so it was a wonderful machine for
getting growth from existing clients and
this was what
bill bain always used to say i have no
idea
why everyone's interested in new clients
we don't need new clients we should have
built-in growth from existing clients if
we're doing our job
correctly if their profits are going up
and the market value is going up
and of course they didn't say no to new
clients and they use the existing
clients
who are satisfied particularly those who
sat as non-executive directors outside
directors
on the boards of other companies to say
you know
i'd like to show you some a sample of
work which
boning company has done in our industry
uh
and i participated in one of those
events in new york
um where i was sort of you know
we were working for an information
company and we went to
um present to a board of that
information company but one of the
people on that board
was the chief executive of a scientific
company
and subsequently they hired a bailing
company largely
because i think of the recommendation of
the chief executive and to a small
degree
the quality of the dazzling quality of
the presentation i made
well you know as a result of that
boning company made me a um a partner
nominally a partner and vice president
whereas i went in as a consultant
and that would normally take several
years well that happened after 18 months
and it was a very interesting
conversation with bill bain
when he told me that i was going to be a
partner of the firm
and what he said to me was richard you
know i'm going to say something which
might surprise you
you know we've had our eye on you ever
since you came and talked to me blah
blah blah
and i want you to be one of my partners
and i thought you know this is
ridiculous i
you know i didn't expect this and he
said but there is something which we're
going to do and i don't think
any other firm in the world has ever
done this not to my knowledge
maybe you can correct me but what they
said was
we are going to promote you but in only
in nine months time
and it's a done deal you know there's no
question that you'll be one of my
partners
and i can even give you something to
sign and sign something myself
but you know if we made you a partner
now people might wonder what on earth we
were doing
in that nine months you've got to behave
as though you're already a partner
without the authority
of being a partner but just through
force of personality and through knowing
that you
are reflecting the main way of doing
things you will
when we actually make the announcement
that you are going to be a partner of
the firm
everyone will say well of course of
course
rather than say how come that cautious
got promoted
that's unbelievable so it's bill was
such a clever man at controlling his
organization
and he didn't work very hard but he
didn't work very long anyway but he gave
a great deal of thought
to the procedures and to the management
of his own company
to make sure that everything that
happened in bail and company had been
initiated in one way or another
by bill bain and make sure that that was
the thing which was going to make the
most money
for bill bain for baining company
and also i'm making it sound as though
it's just an incidental thing but it was
very important it's a whole foundation
of it for the client organization
it was just a fantastically well-run
organization
and it grew at 40 a year for 20 or 30
years whereas bcg had
struggled to grow um at 20
bail and company fell on hard times i
think in the late 1980s because they did
a leveraged buyout but that's another
story
i'm not going to say any more about
burning company
well i'm not going to let you off the
hook that easily you said
you explained rather what bill bain
asked of you to behave like a partner
even though you won't have the official
title and we can't make the announcement
until nine months hence
in practice what did that look like
what changed in your behavior or in what
you did
oh it totally changed me it totally
changed me for one thing it made me
loyal
uh and i was always someone who was on
the verge of
committing you know self-destruction
self-destructing because
because you know i'm a natural rebel you
know i'm i'm not i'm a
non-conformist i'm very opinionated
and almost unemployable and that was the
conclusion that everyone eventually came
to but
but you know it in bcg i was well known
for
going off script and i remember one of
my appraisals
was you know most of the time richard
he's like a volcano
this guy wrote in a formal written
assessment and i've i've still got the
assessment it's lovely
uh he said he's like a volcano most of
the time he's sort of you know
working away and there are no rumblings
and it's all
very very smooth but occasionally
he erupts like a volcano
and he says something to the client
which is not what we want the client to
hear
and he basically goes off a tangent or
he you know he has his own
view about things so when i'm with
richard and talking to the chief
executive of
the new you know big information company
in holland or whatever
i am very nervous
i never know what richard's going to say
in boehner company
that was you know i'd have been fired if
i'd you know if i just if i'd have said
you know my my vice president said
you know something and i said i agree
with 99.9
of that but here's a slightly different
view on 0.1
i'd been out the door straight away so
it was
it was a complete contrast so the first
difference it made
was i was i felt very loyal to bill
personally and to the organization which
i'd never really done before
i didn't do loyalty i didn't really do
teamwork very well
so that was the first difference it made
the second difference it made
was that i decided that i would become
much more
direct with the people who were working
with me if they were the same level
if they were below me in the
organization or even sometimes if
they're slightly above me
but i did it very nicely and so if i
thought they were going in the wrong
direction
i would say well you know i've been
thinking about this
fred and i think there's a better way of
doing it than this
instead of interviewing the customers in
this segment we should interview in that
segment we should ask these questions
rather than those questions
etc etc so it made me much more
paradoxically to me it made me more
diplomatic but it also made me more
assertive
and so you know that was
it was great i mean i actually thought
gosh they're going to make me a partner
and i'm going to be a very successful
partner and that's fantastic
but it made me feel a little cautious
because although bill bonin
signed his bit of paper and all rest i
knew that that was
meant nothing if he wanted to change his
mind
so i thought well the prize is well
within grasp but
i feel confident now that it gave me
confidence
and so i was able to do i was much more
effective as a result of that
in fact i was probably more effective
when i wasn't a partner than i when i
was because i was
i wanted it so much but at the same time
i felt
in some ways although nobody knew that i
had authority
in reality i did and that was a
tremendous thing and i don't understand
why firms don't do this more broadly
it's a fantastic way
of encouraging personal development and
also of keeping people who might
otherwise
decide to leave before they're given the
nod that actually
they are really appreciated and they are
going to get promoted
i was going to ask you more about lek
which was the consultancy you started
which experienced incredible growth and
we may get to that but i want to
skip ahead a little bit and i'm gonna do
that
in a foreshadowing fashion by mentioning
the 80 20 principle which we'll come
back to
in an interview that i have in front of
me a separate interview
the question is what book has had the
single biggest impact on your career
and you answer my own book the 80 20
principle because it's sold more than a
million copies and it's been translated
into more than 35 languages
it goes on and on about that which we're
going to return to
and then you say at the end of the
answer that
many of your books and much of your
investing are related to ideas on
strategy
consulting and you learn those first
hand not from books but that you can
recommend a book called perspectives on
strategy edited by
carl stern and george stock can you
speak to
what people might learn in that book and
why
you have recommended it it's a
collection of
the early perspectives of the boston
consulting group
and a perspective was what um
evangelical group would call attract i
suppose
it would be something like 500 words
maybe a thousand words
pretty short it would be snazzily
presented in the livery of bcg which was
a very
quite a nice dark green color um
and it would be mailed to the senior
directors of companies
in america and britain and then wherever
bcg had offices
and the very valuable thing about the
book is
a lot of the stuff is by bruce henderson
himself
but there's also more modern stuff and
it outlines the theory that bcg had in
the early days which i think is still
entirely valid
of competition the experience curve
the boston box the grocery matrix etc
and it's just a very very good primer
and there are many many books on
business strategy
including one which i've written but uh
i think this is a very
very good thing and it's very easy to
read because it was deliberately
designed
to do that bruce laid out the principles
for the perspectives very clearly
which was anything that the chief
executive would be likely to agree with
was not argued i mean it was stated
and anything that the chief executive
would be likely to disagree with which
was
quite a lot because bcg was on the
mission of saying companies should
reduce their costs and reduce their
prices steadily
whereas the conventional wisdom in
business at that time was if you get a
higher price
you know stick with it and don't worry
too much about the costs
and bruce had a whole theology around
that and it was
it's great because it's a collection of
those different perspectives and it's
over several years so you get the more
modern stuff as well i think it was
published in 2000 or something like that
so it is difficult to get good books on
strategy there's a there's a book
by someone called richard oh god i can't
remember his name called
um good strategy bad strategy he'll come
back to me but anyway you
type it into amazon if you want good
strategy bad strategy that's actually a
very good strategy book very not very
nice short
strategy book and there's my financial
times guide to strategy we don't give a
small plug dude
out of print at the moment but i'm
producing the fifth
fifth edition as we well not as we speak
but
but at the same time in the same period
of time
good strategy bad strategy by richard
rumelt
does that sound correct god isn't the
web amazing aren't you amazing
it'd be far more incredibly i was
actually pressing the keys and came up
with that myself but i don't do that
well i'll give away one of my tricks and
that is if i'm recording
an interview like this i don't use my
keyboard i have my phone on silent so
that i can tap
the screen without making noise to find
things like that
you're very clever well you do that you
can have you can have a funky who did
that for you but it's very impressive
that you do it yourself that's true well
it's just for
on the spot tap dancing like that
earlier in the conversation
i i made a promise to the listeners and
that was
in the form of alluding to knowledge
versus principles which i think is
perhaps a useful way to
segue to the 80 20 principle and
from mergers and inquisitions.com which
is a great website the distinction
that i've read you drawing is
the following what i learned from
consulting is exactly what i've been
teaching knowledge is great but
principles are better principles are
ideas that enable you to sort the
knowledge help you to analyze it and get
to the essence of the matter
as simply and quickly as possible would
you like to add anything to why
principles
are important and the second part of
that is how did the 80 20 principle
come to be as a book because it was a
very much and sort of underground became
an underground bestseller so
principles anything more that you would
like to add and then where did this book
come from
no i think you put it very well i just
think you know
there are certain meta principles and i
think there are probably only about half
a dozen of them
for the benefit of myself and the people
that i work with and um
invest with invest in rather it's
basically the 80 20 principle and the
staff principle
so if you know what those are
then you can look at the business in a
way that most people don't look at
business
very quickly and see whether there's
potential for improvement
and we'll talk about that in regard to
the 80 20 principle in a second no doubt
but um how did the book come about well
again that's quite interesting at least
interesting to me
which is that i wrote something called
the a to z
of management because i had a an
editor who was currently working at
pearson and later
left to start his own firm with another
editor there and the editor was called
mark allen the other editor was called
richard burton very very
skilled guys very nice guys and they
were looking to sort of you know
try and get something by me published
and mark allen said to me you've written
this thing called the ages editor
management which is basically
a paragraph about various different
concepts and it covered all the
principles i could think of it also
covered um
important theorists in business
and it covered anything which was of
of interest in business and it also
covered
jargon phrases like you know what did
what did people mean by work in progress
and
stuff like that anyway i'd written half
a page
on the 80 20 principle and i went to see
mark allen
one day in his offices in covent garden
and
he said to me richard i've got a book
for you to write
i said yeah and he said what about
writing a book about the 80 20 principle
because you've got this half page on it
here and it seems to be quite an
important thing you say it's very
important
and i can understand it's very important
so why don't you write a book on that i
said ma i couldn't possibly
i could possibly write a book about the
80 20 principle you know
i've said it all in that paragraph
and you know i could maybe pad it out
to a page you know if you really put a
gun to my head
i could write a chapter but i'm not
going to write a whole bloody book
about this because there isn't anything
more to say
and he said well i'm not so sure about
that
then he decided that he would go off and
start this other publishing company so
he wasn't interested in
me doing it for them and they had not
got themselves organized so i went to
see
a guy called nicholas brealy who was the
publisher of the eponymous firm nicholas
really
and very very very nice member
incredibly smart guy
and i'd written a book for him called
managing without management which was a
title which he suggested it was very
clever because it basically said
managing a particular middle managing
was a complete waste
of time and so you could manage without
it managing without management
and the book wasn't a huge success but
it sold i don't know 20 000 coppers
which
was was good enough for for nicolas
really at that time
and i went to see him about uh
another book shortly after i'd had the
conversation with mark allen and
he said do you have another book in mind
i said well not really
but there's this sort of idea that
someone's given me
and you know they've got first dibs on
the on publishing
if if i could ever write a book about it
but i don't think i could write a book
about it
and then i described him what the 80 20
principle was and honestly i didn't take
more than about 60 seconds because
there wasn't much to say as far as i was
concerned and he said the hairs on the
back of my head
are rising and i said what do you mean
i thought i thought he lost the plot or
something
and he said that can be a big successful
book and i said
no i mean yeah well maybe but
but you know how do i pad it out to a
book's length he said go and do some
research
you know you've mentioned bill frodo
pareto you know read the book again
read all the other stuff read all the
stuff on the web you know and the truth
was that there was a hell of a lot of
stuff
on the internet and this was back in
1996 but was eventually published in
1997.
you know this was a golden beginning of
the golden period of the internet and i
you know and i hired a researcher and
said find out
everything that's going on on the
internet on the 80 20 principle at that
stage
i didn't know how to use the internet
and um
so she came back and gave me his whole
whole file and i said diane is that
all about the 8020 principle and she
said yes
and i said well maybe i could write a
book
so anyway i went through it all and the
more i went into it the deeper it it
actually and the more interesting it was
and so that's how i
ended up writing books so i went back to
my original guy mark allen said do you
want to publish this book he said no we
can't we
left pearson at the time and um
we haven't started our firm yet so i
went back to nicholas briley and he was
very pleased and
and uh and that you know the first draft
i produced
he said very very politely he said i
think you're going to need to go and do
some more
research and it was it was pretty
hopeless actually
uh but the second draft i took back and
he more or less published
it as as it was because by that stage i
worked it through
and it was a it was a great thinking
exercise for me and
the the whole point about making a book
out of it
was that i extended the reach of the
principle
so the principle the basic 80 20
principles i'm sure nearly all your
listeners know is that if you look at
any particular relationship between
sales
and another variable or you look at time
and another variable you might be
interested in
it's usually true that there are very
few
events or data which account for a large
majority of the total
and so if you look at the profits of any
company
by customer usually there are a very
small
number of customers a very small
proportion of the total who account for
80 percent of the sales and maybe more
than 100
of the profits of a company and likewise
if you do the same thing
for products you're likely to find the
same thing
and this this was a well-known economic
concept that anyone had been to business
school and heard it was generally called
the
pareto rule at that time but i wanted to
call it the 8020 principle because it
was more descriptive
a rule to me sounded too deterministic
principle sounded to me exactly right
and so
so i actually invented i think the eight
to twenty percent
anyone ever called it that beforehand
they would they would call it the 80 20
rule or the pareto rule
and so it was
the idea seemed to me to be applicable
well beyond
the sphere that had been used before
which was for
really analyzing sales and profits
and i said well why can't we use the 80
20 principle
in other areas in people's personal
lives for example
and so i i became quite fascinated by
the connection between
time and results
and then it was a short hop from that to
extend that so so basically i would say
to people well
the hypothesis and the whole thing about
the 80 20 principle is not that it's a
rule but it's a
an observation so you you come up with a
hypothesis and then you test whether
it's true
with data if you possibly can but with
you know seeing if you think it really
is true if it's
something much more subjective and
squishy so
you you actually could then say well
it's probably true
it may be true that 20 of your time
generates 80
of your useful output so tell me what
the most valuable things are that you do
and i would say that to people at work
and they would have no difficulty at all
and saying well
it was inventing this new product or it
was selling a large
job to this particular customer or it
was writing some copy which is you know
very very effective or it was
making a website or whatever it was and
i would say to them well
you know you've got to do more of that
and less of the other stuff
and i'd also say to people that if you
manage to do something
which is you know hugely more valuable
than the other stuff and you do that in
half a day
take the rest of the day off and if you
do that for two days take the rest of
the week off
if you want to you know if you want to
carry on working and do even more that's
right
but you know as parkinson said work
expands to fill the time available
spending expands to fill the budget
which you've got to spend it whether
it's inside a firm or it's your own
money
i was quite interested incidentally
in hearing an observation
which one of your other interviewees
said
about the wall street of the uh well i
don't know was it 1980s or whatever
and that you know basically people got
very very used to the
money which they'd earned they were
hugely overpaid
but uh nevertheless they found ways to
use that
and that was a big trap for them not for
him but
for the others because what they did was
that they got locked into
working for salomon brothers or goldman
sachs or whatever and after a time they
couldn't really leave
because their wives or their their own
personal tastes had
had developed to such an extent or their
husbands
they needed the money you know they had
to have half a million dollars a year
they couldn't live on less so i was
saying to people well
let's extend this to your personal life
as well
so if time is important at work then
maybe time is important
elsewhere and maybe you get most of your
happiness from a relatively small
proportion
of your time what are the periods of
time where you actually feel
that you are being fulfilled that you
feel you don't notice
time escaping you know when when
you feel that this is great and you wake
up and you fight you find that you know
the night's gone it might be playing
poker
you know it might be talking to friends
it might be reading something it's very
exciting
might be going to see a movie or
whatever but what are the times that you
are happiest
and then just try and multiply those
times and then i said well you could
apply that to friends
let's take the 80 20 hypothesis that you
get 80
of your relationship satisfaction from
20 percent of people i mean it's a bit
gross in a way
but it's very true i mean i found when
talking to people
that very often they spent time with
people
they didn't really like very much i mean
obviously
sometimes it was their boss so you know
that was a disaster
and they probably will better get a
different boss or a different firm
but sometimes it was as simple as things
like well
your spouse actually liked these people
but you didn't
so you ended up spending a lot of time
with neighbors or with other
people or members of his or her family
that you didn't really want to spend
and what you really wanted to spend your
time on was something different
and so i said to people well you know
you might want to be a bit more ruthless
about that and so there's a chapter on
happiness
in the book which i was rereading
recently and i think it's actually
rather good
i mean it's taking the sort of rather
arcane dusty economic principle
and then seeing uh whether it could
apply to other areas of life
and i invented the concept of happiness
islands well happiness island is part of
your life which is sort of not the main
part of the life
but when you get a huge amount of
satisfaction from that
and i said well live on those happiness
islands and try if possible to make them
happiness continents
so if there's a particular type of work
which you like doing at work
then try and get yourself in a position
where you're spending all your time
doing that sort of work
and so on and so forth and i see it in
many ways as a kind of amateur
version of the flow idea
which is that you know these times
according to the guy with the
unpronounceable name um
something like that yeah and he's he's
written a couple of books about this it
all boils down i mean i think that
i say 80 20 principle could be written
on one page i think that could all be
written on one page but
but it's a fantastic idea it's a it's a
slightly more sophisticated way of
saying
what i was trying to say and there's
stuff on there in money and and all the
rest of it
so it was a reinterpretation of
the principle to apply it to not just to
business to but to people's personal
lines and to try and say a few things
which were really useful
uh and which people could take away
which is what you do isn't it
that's what i try to do it's what i
certainly try to do and
for all the reasons you just mentioned
and many more this is why the 80
20 principle your book faces cover out
on my bookshelf and hez for a very very
long time as a constant reminder
could you share just as examples because
it may help people listening
some examples of your own happiness
islands
or achievement islands yes i can do that
the things that i really like doing are
writing books
and making money and making money
through investments not through
through gambling or anything like that
and talking to people
i really used to like going to dinner
parties in the days when we had dinner
parties
i really like to go for long walks of
people that
uh not many people but a few people that
i know
we will discover something that we
didn't know we knew beforehand
um those are the things that really are
interesting doing something like this
podcast is
as a flow activity as far as i'm
concerned an 80 20
activity so it's that sort of stuff
it's it's books it's writing books
it's also reading books and it's
it's talking to people and it's also
making money through investments
do you have any regular or scheduled
check-ins or calendared reviews
where you assess your life to ensure
that you're allocating your time and
energy to match what you know to be
happiness islands or achievement islands
in other words how do you use
if you do in any systematic way the 80
20 principle
in your life no is the short answer but
let me qualify that a little bit
i do something which is very
unsophisticated other people have
therapists
and other people have uh personal
trainers
and other people have you know quite
elaborate systems for
for keeping track of their objectives or
their concerns their worries
and so on and so forth i have bike rides
every day i go for a two-hour bike ride
in the countryside
it is every day unless i'm in a unless
i'm
away or unless i'm in cape town i've got
a home in cape town it's too dangerous
to ride a bicycle
there but everywhere else i will ride a
bicycle
and i take pretty much the same route
every day
very unadventurous i've got two
alternative routes in in portugal for
example
and during those bike rides
something will come up sometimes not
very often but
something will always come up at the
very least i will work out what i'm
going to do that
day because that's what i that's one
output from a bike ride and it just
happens automatically i don't even have
to think about it
when do you do the bike rides i presume
in the morning in the morning yeah
uh i don't i don't um answer emails i
don't look at my phone
i do have a cup of tea and sometimes i
take the dog for a walk but apart from
that
it's the bike ride and it's it's it's
wonderful i mean
you know i couldn't do without it and in
fact when i'm away and i can't
ride a bicycle i'm talking to you from
gibraltar for example and i do spend
a fair bit of time in gibraltar where i
have an apartment
but here it's also too dangerous to ride
because the
streets are too narrow and there i have
to substitute going for a walk
or going to the gym but basically a form
of exercise which is mindless which is
you know not
not too difficult but enjoyable
where i can just relax and let my
unconscious mind do whatever it does
that's how i do those sort of things and
occasionally i go and sit on my fish
pond
with a notebook and say it's time to
think about
some reflections i make a point of only
doing that
when i'm in a good mood i never do it
when i'm actually feeling slightly down
i'm usually in a good mood but it's
something to do when you're being
expensive rather than you're doubting
yourself
and you know i keep most of those
notebooks and
very occasionally also i wake up in the
middle of the night
and i have thought of something that i
had not thought of before
and then i have a notebook by the bed or
if if it's not by the bed it's
in my office which is very close to my
bedroom and so
i will make a cup of tea put the light
on write my thoughts
uh put the book down put the lies out go
to sleep
and and those thoughts are usually
quite seminal i mean they're they're
very very helpful but it all happens
sort of automatically i don't have any
systems or anything like that
do you ha well i would say i have
acute hypergraphia and copious
notes most of which end up never being
read
and certainly most of which end up being
uh completely unimportant but
amongst all the garbage there are
occasionally
useful things i find journaling very
helpful for me
different forms it's the writing which
is important isn't it it's the writing
the writing somehow ingrains it on your
mind when you when you do do you find
that that
that how do you find that it's not as
you say one may
never review the notes i do actually
review my notebooks when i'm on a plane
and got nothing better to do
and no book to read but um
but it isn't that it's actually the
process
of i think the process of writing
journaling is very very
very useful but i don't do it every day
and i don't do it systematically i just
do it when i feel the need to do it
i i would say i have two different types
of journaling and then i'd like to ask
you about your time at the pond in a
moment and just
what that actually looks like and maybe
some examples from what you've written
down
i would say i have two types of
journaling the first is almost
entirely like emptying the
the garbage bin on a mac to purge the
system
it is simply to trap my monkey mind and
all of the
bullets ricocheting around inside my
mind on paper so that i can get on
with my day in a better fashion the
second type is more
deliberate and objective driven where i
might
sit down and very
explicitly do an 80 20 analysis of the
types
that that you've been describing looking
at how my time is being used look at my
calendar to see if it actually
matches what i say is important to me
etc so there are
i'd say there's two main categories
morning pages
from uh julia cameron's template would
be in in the former as
an example but when you go to the pond
and you sit down and you're in an
expansive mood
and you journal what does that look like
is it
stream of consciousness are there
certain prompts that you might use could
you give us any real world examples
of what has come from those types of
sessions
yes i mean what i do is i write
reflections and i put
the date and then i put numbers and then
i just start writing
and you know one one of the things that
comes out from that which can't wait
which came out from that
recently was thinking about my
investments
and i was struck by the fact that i was
average to say i was average timing each
investment was would not be
fair but i was spending a lot of time on
stuff that
actually wasn't at all
important and i was doing it partly
through interest partly because i
perhaps felt some residual sense of
obligation to the people who
were managing the firm and other
shareholders
so you know one of the things which i
decided was i was not going to
worry about any companies which were
outside the first
you know half dozen in terms of the
value of those companies unless the
value was increasing very fast or it had
the potential to increase very fast
and the other thing which i realized
because i'm always
you know almost completely invested was
that that was not actually a terribly
sensible thing to do and the next time i
have a major
realization i should be prepared
and i should have two or three companies
which are new companies
in other words investments i have not
yet made where
they do have the potential to be star
businesses or they
already are star businesses where i like
the people involved and that's a
cinequa known for me that i don't invest
in things unless i actually like the
people
and uh where you know a relatively small
amount of money
might conceivably be another betfair or
whatever so it's it's quite easy for me
because i've got a couple of companies
are increasing in value quite fast and
i'm reasonably confident that they will
continue to do so the next
few years to be sort of you know rather
complacent about that but
you know to in order to maintain the
sort of rate of return that i've had
historically and that i want
i probably need to find a new yeah a new
betfair or two or three new bet fairs
over the next five years and i should
give
a bit more attention to trawling for
that and
talking to my contacts that might
conceivably know
such companies and actually you know i
do get some leads and
don't always follow them up very well so
so um
yes so it can be useful from that point
of view
and the other thing which i've realized
as a result of journaling
in the last few months is that i am too
socially isolated i mean i've got some
very good friends
i don't see them as often as i as i
would like
and because i have such a really nice
life
living in very pretty places and living
in sunny places generally which is very
important for me to be outdoors
so that i can play tennis or ride the
bicycle or sit on the fish pond or
whatever
it's i ought to pay more attention
to social interaction and to spending
more time with the people that iron
spend
enjoy spending time but they're not not
close to where i am
so those are sort of conclusions which
have come up in the last six months
and then there are the more
philosophical conclusions which you
sometimes come to
and which sometimes you write down for
example
one of the things which i've learned in
the last few years is
i have been far too much of what i call
a controller
and far too little of what i call an
adventurer
and um you know my life has always run
upon lines of saying i must do this i
must achieve this i must make this sort
of amount of money i must have this type
of job i must do this kind of thing i
must start a company
and so on and so forth but recently
i i have realized that the people have
most fun in life
are more the adventurer type than the
controllers in fact
to come back something that i hope we're
going to spend a little bit of time on
later on
which is my new book unreasonable
success and how to achieve it
there are 20 people who changed the
world in my opinion in the
in that book and it it's not in the book
at all but it's something which i did
after the event i divided those
very successful people into controllers
and adventurers and i was quite
surprised to find the
14 of them were actually adventurous in
one form or another
and only six of them were controllers
there were some who were
both but but you know that was the count
taking halves into account
and for example one of the people who
was a controller
in the book was sort of my evil
evil successful person uh which was
vladimir lenin
and you know his life was pretty
unpleasant uh
because he was always trying to control
other people and it was a
very uphill struggle and he achieved a
great deal in his terms i mean not
things
i would approve of but he was the
founder of practical communism
and he basically made communism a
success in
very large parts of the world a success
in the sense that they remained
communist
and they did develop the country's work
perhaps not as fast as they would have
developed under a free market system
but you know from that point of view he
was he was very very successful but he
didn't have much of a great time
whereas some of the people who were much
more freewheeling
for example the freewheeling bob dylan
or even
otto von bismarck they had much more fun
because they although they were
determined to achieve things they relied
upon events flowing their way and they
just bided their time until the right
moment came along and then they
then they worked then they basically um
made a huge effort to control or not not
control events but to
to actually steer them one of the great
quotes which i like
is from bismarck who said man cannot
control
the flow of events all he can do is ride
with them and steer
so i you know sometimes you get those
sort of kind of philosophical
reflections
uh coming up more often though probably
on a bike ride and then i might write it
down afterwards
but i actually find it quite difficult
to be
as radical as that um just sitting down
and writing i tend to write
you know things which are they're much
less important in a way they're less
distant let's uh this was on my
my my next note to segue into that is
the new books
let's let's talk about the the genesis
story
and this is always interesting to me as
someone who occasionally
tries to wordsmith things and that is
the
the sort of embarrassment of riches that
you no doubt have
in terms of possible subjects you could
explore so
unreasonable success in how to achieve
it you've written many books why
this book i've always been fascinated by
success and i've always been fascinated
by the discrepancy really
between as i see it the arbitrary nature
of success in many ways which is that
the people who
are successful are not necessarily the
people who are most intelligent or most
expected to succeed
or who um deserve it you know
and many of the people many of the 20
people that i highlight in the book
weren't even competent and winston
churchill was prime example of someone
who was complete failure through most of
his career
got one thing right which was hitler was
a threat to the world and that he knew
how to deal with hitler
but but basically uh the man was
a disaster and he thought that oratory
would propel him to become prime
minister
but you know as herbert asquith said
it does not matter if you speak with the
tongues of men and angels if nobody
trusts you and it was a
it was directed exactly at churchill
so i've always been fascinated by
success but the actual
genesis of the book as you said came on
a train journey i was traveling from
paris with a friend of mine
to lyon and i always take a book with me
and i didn't have a book a new book that
i wanted to read so i took an old book
which was malcolm gladwell's outliers
and you probably remember that in
outliers the whole thesis
is success derives from deep experience
and long exposure to doing
something in a very narrow field
and he came up with the idea of the 10
000 hours which is now
a trope something which everyone talks
about
and he gave a couple of examples very
early on in the book which
resonate very nicely which is the
beatles for example in 1960 they were
just a rather
poor high street band and then something
happened to them which was that they
went off to
the strip clubs of hamburg and they had
to play
seven days a week eight hours a day
and as john lennon was quoted in the
book as saying we couldn't help improve
with all of that extra experience
and then he quotes the example of bill
gates who because he went to a private
school which
unlike the vast majority of schools at
the time
in america or anywhere else had got
computers
you know he was able to acquire
expertise in coding and
and uh how to use computers and that was
his sort of you know he got his ten
thousand hours in very
very quickly so the the problem with
that
thesis is that it's not universally true
it certainly applies to bill gates it
certainly applies
to the beatles and it applies to some
other people as well
but of the people that i looked at that
couldn't explain it and what i did was i
took 20 people whose life stories i knew
well some in some cases i knew them
personally such as bruce henderson and
bill bain who i talked about before
who were very important to me and hugely
underrated in terms of the impact which
they've had
on american and world business in my in
my opinion
but i took those people and then i said
would it be possible to do what malcolm
gladwell set out to do
and in my opinion did not succeed in
doing would it be possible to look at
the causes
of success for those people and identify
things which were common to all
20 people which they all had
or did it might be an experience that
they had or it might be
an attitude which they had or it might
be a way that they exploited particular
opportunities would it be possible to
look at that
and say that there are things which are
so universally present that if you want
to be what i call
unreasonably successful which is more
than you deserve if you like
does it terrifically successful in
changing the world the way you want to
work
change it it might be a small corner of
the world or it might be a big corner of
the world
would it be possible to isolate the
reasons for that
and i looked at 50 possible reasons for
example i looked at you know would you
need to be a high risk taker and the
answer was
of those 20 people only nine of them
actually took very high risk of 20
people in my book
um only only nine of them actually took
uh very high risk so that went went away
and then i narrowed it down to nine
reasons
uh which were universally present in all
of the cases and i did not
i did not throw people out if they
didn't meet the nine
requirements i was quite rigorous with
myself i said no and the people
like the the the players that i took
were besides bill bone and bruce
henderson there was jeff bezos
otto van bismark winston churchill marie
curie
leonardo leonardo da vinci walt disney
bob dylan
albert einstein victor frankl the guy
who was shoved into a concentration camp
by hitler but came up with the third
wave of psychology after
freud and adler and was probably the
first real existential philosopher
bruce henderson mentioned steve jobs
john maynard keynes who saved the world
from fascism and communism perhaps as a
result of
saying that you didn't have to have very
high unemployment
and the state could step in and that
would be fine um
under a liberal capitalist regime lenin
i mentioned
madonna nelson mandela totally obscured
guy
who was imprisoned on robben island 17
years
but somehow managed to negotiate
a democracy in south africa jk rowling
helena rubinstein formed the eponymous
cosmetics company before anybody else
had a cosmetics company
the person who i think was most
successful of all of my 20 people
paul of tarsus i don't like calling him
saint paul because it makes him sound
you know an establishment figure he was
never an establishment figure he had
this vision of the living christ
and he preached that throughout the
roman world
but he did something that none of the
other followers of jesus did which as
you said
you know following a jewish customer
base if you like
is not the way to make a new religion
take off we don't want to be a very
small sect within judaism
i actually want to convert people in the
whole world
and therefore what we need to do is to
turn
you know that sort of jewish religion
that jesus had
had been enveloped within and take away
from that the things which
actually were universally applicable
so you know without paul what eventually
emerged as christianity would never have
either achieved liftoff
nor transcended its jewish roots so
fantastically successful
you know i mean who would have thought
that christianity could actually
succeed it was just a miracle margaret
thatcher was the other
was the other one of the 20 people so i
came up with these
nine things which which were common to
all of them
and i'll i'll rattle through those if if
you like definitely
feel free to list the nine but before we
do that if you could just take a moment
to define success
since many people define success
differently could you speak to what that
means in the context of
unreasonable success is it achieving
what they set out to do
or is it something else and then what i
would love to know what the
the nine characteristics are yes it is i
think
success is very subjective and can only
be the person's objectives
and you know i'd i mean people said to
me why how how on earth can you put
lenin in the book and in fact at one
stage i had hitler in the book and that
publishers insisted on it being thrown
out because they said the book sellers
would never said
if you see the book i said well we don't
like hitler in favor of hitler
i said no hitler's got to go so it's
it's value-free
in the sense that it is what they
achieved which changed the world
the way they wanted to change it whether
that was a good thing or a bad thing or
an indifferent thing that's that's
unreasonable success in one definition
success is a is a whole continuum as far
as i'm concerned
and you know i'm not against minor
successes at all
absolutely great but what i was really
interested in in order to establish
the the most important causes of major
success
is what i call unreasonable success and
i had four
criteria for that you could say that in
a word it's undeserved success but
that's that's a little bit unfair
firstly it's such success in changing
the world it seems unreasonable for one
individual to do that i mean we live in
a world which is quite collective
and which is governed by culture and
constraints which are quite immovable we
think the world's changing very fast but
in many ways the world doesn't change
very fast
and then suddenly it does and what
usually is behind that is not a huge
number of people
doing something is an individual
deciding to do something and managing to
persuade other people to do that
so it's unreasonable in the sense that
one person has all of that impact
secondly is success that is unexpected
and was not predicted
when the individual was young or early
in their career
so it's kind of you know it's success
which comes from nowhere
thirdly it's success that goes well
beyond what the individual's skills and
performance seemed to warrant
and winston churchill jolly good example
of that some would say that
the british prime minister boris johnson
is an example of that
completely disastrous uh foreign
secretary
probably completely incompetent in his
dealing with the corona virus
but nevertheless i think may well go
down in history as a great prime
minister because he has certain
objectives that he wants to achieve like
making sure britain did leave the
european union
and maybe doing something about the
excessive price of housing in britain
the fact that it's almost impossible for
young people
to actually buy a house these days and
also
you know britain's a hugely over
centralized country
london-centric country and there are
left behind areas of britain which
basically is most of the rest that's not
in the south east of britain
and i think boris johnson wants to do
something about that and if he's able to
do that that would be a fantastic
achievement i know that you're
interested in very practical things so
in the book i discuss
what do you do if you don't have
self-belief and for example one of the
things that you can do
is to realize it has to be in a specific
domain or
context and so you've got to identify
that context where you could really
change things
secondly find a fantasy man mentor
now this is quite an i think it's quite
an interesting and
perhaps original concept i was driven to
it by
studying bob dylan because
here this guy arrived in new york
completely unknown
19 years old but with
a fantastically high ambition
and one of the things which he did was
to seek out woody guthrie who was
probably the template that he wanted
which was woody guthrie had been not
only
a folk singer but also a protester
really
and also someone who wrote his own songs
and in fact that was very unusual at the
time and folk songs were meant to be
sort of arose from the folk not from
individuals
and guthrie actually changed that he
wrote a lot of original songs
and dylan did too he started writing his
own songs one of which was called
the ode to woody and he went to the
hospital in new jersey where
woody guthrie was suffering from a
terrible terrible disease called
huntington's syndrome and
whether or not guthrie was really aware
that dylan was there whether he actually
thought dylan was
um going to
be the new woody guthrie is really
unclear but it's curiously irrelevant as
well because
because bob dylan took from that
template that's what he had to do he had
to write his own original songs he had
to claim the heritage
of guffery as some something which would
perhaps get him some publicity and
attention
and somehow he managed to get a contract
with the all of the folk
labels rejected him but columbia records
which was a blue chip
you know firm obviously uh signed him
and then
you know that gave him confidence and he
gave him contacts and it gave him gigs
and goodness knows what else
and he was able to produce albums and
and you know
then he was made and also of course he
hijacked in the sense that
the protest movement with songs like you
know blowing in the wind etc
which made him according to certain
people the
voice of the generation so it's another
way to find a fantasy mentor
thirdly to search for transforming
experiences and i'll say something about
that in a minute
and fourthly to attract well-deserved
praise
when i'll say something about one
breakthrough achievement also
in a moment and then narrow your focus
until
your work is unique well this these are
some of those
are landmarks as well so the first one
being self-belief the second one
is olympian expectations that you expect
a huge amount from yourself and then
from other people
and the high priest of high expectations
is probably jeff bezos who's always
banging on about this
and you know really believes everyone in
the senior management team has to be an
absolute a player class a player
and he says you know if you put someone
who's not used to high expectations on a
high expectations team they will adapt
but the reverse is also true if you have
people who are not
high expectation people they're not
people's standards will slip
and one thing that bezos has been
incredibly good at doing
is having the highest possible standards
you know he's his
mantra his customer service and
unbeatable prices and he's totally
inflexible on all that
so the second thing is olympian
expectations
the third one which is particularly
interesting because it's really original
i think and i was thrilled to discover
this in my research is transforming
experiences
every single one of these people had
actually
a an experience which transformed them
in the sense that they went into the
experience
as one sort of person and they came out
as another sort of person or
as someone who is a hundred times more
powerful
or more effective every single one of
them had that experience and again to
take bezos as an example of that
before he founded amazon he was a failed
investment banker aged 26 and a
headhunter decided to
send him as a last resort
to see a guy called david shaw who had
founded
a counter cultural quantitative
investment hedge fund and
shaw realized before anyone else did in
by about 1992
that the internet was going to be huge
and that it could be huge
not just for information and all other
things but for selling things for
retailing
and so his idea was that
that his firm which was called desco de
shaw and company
should develop a program for
selling over the internet and then it
should start a company to do that
and he put bezos as the project leader
on that and he
and bezos got on very well like a house
on fire they're the same
extremely quantitative extremely nerdy
extremely ambitious sort of people and
between the two of them they developed
the
format for amazon and they decided
the first category that they would go
into was books
and they decided that they would allow
people to write reviews on the sites
etc etc etc it was
amazon blueprint as it happened and
um of course david shaw wanted that to
happen within desco
but one day bezos went to david and said
i really want to do it myself
and david shaw took him for a little
two-hour walk around central park in
which he tried to dissuade him
but incredibly generously david shaw
allowed
bezos to go off and and and found out he
didn't even ask for a share in the
company
but then that was david shaw he was a
very very self-confident guy
and his firm has been amazingly
successful anyway
so that was a transforming experience
for
bezos for we talked earlier about bill
bain transforming experience for him
was getting hired by bcg by bruce
henderson
when he was the completely unqualified
guy who'd never done any business never
done a business degree didn't understand
economics or whatever
managed a history researcher who managed
to get a job as a development officer
at vanderbilt university where he met
bruce henderson
and bruce henderson who had a tremendous
nose for talent
then decided to hire bill bain and bill
bain talked to
boston consulting at bcg like a duck to
water
because he was a very very smart guy and
because the power of the concepts the
concepts were so great and bill
and bruce developed them together
essentially and then bill decided to do
the dirty
on bruce and leave and form his own
firm we would never have heard of bill
bain if it had not been for bruce
henderson just meeting him and deciding
to hire him and the
formative experience of working within
bcg
let me ask you a question if i could
richard and i imagine you you might get
to this
and i i'm sure you have an answer for it
but before we move
ahead if someone has not had a
transforming experience
one might wonder if they're listening to
this
is it possible to engineer a
transforming experience or do i
sit on my head and wait for lady luck to
smile upon absolutely that's the whole
point i mean one of the things i say in
the book is
the whole point of trying to identify
these nine landmarks
is that the people who actually visited
them
didn't intend to and you know
they didn't actually say i need a
transforming experience let's have one
they happen to them i mean for example
the transforming experience of margaret
thatcher was having the falkland islands
invaded by general gartieri of
argentina and she said that was the
worst moment in her life but it was
absolutely the making as it happened
of her and the experience of living
through that
and commanding the armed forces and
doing what everyone said was impossible
which was recovering the the islands
made it possible for her then to do what
she really wanted to do which was
in her opinion reverse national decline
of britain
so yes the people who had these
transforming experiences did not
engineer them but having
seen how important it is
understanding that that you cannot in my
opinion
admittedly from a relatively small
sample but it's amazing that every
single one of these people had a
transforming experience which is
described in the book and i did not fake
it i just you know i didn't
throw anyone out because they hadn't had
a transforming experience and i stuck to
the rules
you can then say well i'd better have a
transform experience haven't i
and then you come to the question well
what is the the most likely type of
transforming experience which will put
me in luck's path
in order to then become much more
powerful
so it could be going to a particular
university and studying something which
is very
arcane and unusual it could be
finding a very high growth firm like bcg
or boston consulting group
or de shoring company and then
joining that firm when it's still very
young
because you won't be on the forefront of
developing you see
thing about companies in their early
days is that they don't know what
they're doing
and so if you don't know what you're
doing you can be very creative about and
if you're involved in that process
you discover things that you never knew
that you had
and not only that you become identified
with them and you become powerful and
you become
perhaps a large shareholder in the
company and
it's completely different from joining a
company which is
you know the on tram lines which we're
basically
not going to do anything radical and
anything new it's so exciting
to actually be part of the company
that's growing very fast doesn't really
know what it's doing
but it's got something some rare
knowledge
which actually means that it can be very
very successful
and it doesn't have to be company it
could be a social organization
it could be a way of thinking it could
be anything that's growing very fast
and where it's unformed and where you
think you've got
some affinity with it and the ability to
contribute and be creative it's not easy
to specify what someone's transforming
experience should be
but i've tried it on a few friends and
and good acquaintances and it's amazing
that actually
we do in the end come up with something
which might actually work
in some cases has before we get to the
fourth i just want to say a few
things the first is that my experience
maps very well to a few of the things
that you just described in the sense
that when i was graduating from
college and was suffering from all sorts
of
quarter life crisis existential angst
about what to do with my life and i
asked a mentor
at the time what i should do what type
of
sector i should go into and his answer
was it doesn't matter as long as it's
growing very quickly you want to be in
something that is
growing quickly not in a sector that is
in decline or stagnant and that ended up
being exceptional advice
and i've found that it also applies to
where you place yourself that is to say
one of the reasons
by example that i left san francisco
after effectively a decade was that i
felt like it was a
a place experiencing some degree of
stagnation
or even in decline and i moved to austin
texas which was very much
a startup of a city it was rapidly
growing expanding
where it was it was still taking shape
and still could be shaped so i just
wanted to
reinforce what you said and on that
point
or i should say moving on from that
point what is the
fourth of of the nine landmarks
yes i mean growth is growth is
everything i mean it ties in with the
star principle uh yes the fourth one
is one breakthrough achievement now this
is different
tim from the other eight
landmarks in that it is not a how to do
it it's a what to do
and in some ways it's a bit odd of me to
put it forth
because it's the combination of
everything else and all the others
really lead to this but i wanted to put
it in the book fairly early
because i wanted people to be thinking
about this as they go through
which is you know what on earth are you
going to do
to change the world and you're not going
to succeed
unless it's something really dramatic or
he's not going to succeed
being unreasonably successful so
you need to start thinking about that it
might take you a decade it might take
you several decades
actually work out what it is but it's
it has to be something that you believe
needs to be done
it's not a way of making you successful
it's a way of changing the world and if
you define it in those terms
it again it's surprising you can
actually come to some kind of resolution
some kind of
opinion and for example once
uh lenin had had his transforming
experience which was the
hanging of his beloved elder brother
that he
idolized and adored because he
was implicated in an assassination
attempt to bizarre
when he was 16 years old lenin heard
that his brother had been hanged
instantly he decided that his whole
purpose in life was to smash the
bourgeoisie and to cause revolution in
russia
that was his and it was a ridiculous you
know 16 year old school boy
ridiculous idea and he wasn't political
at all before he wasn't he was a very
nice sort of you know
everyone liked him but he became very
bitter and twisted but
also very effective so it's it's one
breakthrough achievement which
and it's not two and it's not three and
it's not one every five years
it's something that you do which it
actually is going to in some way change
change the world i mean my my
breakthrough achievement was starting or
co-starting
lek and it's not on the comparable scale
with people in the book
but nevertheless it was a you know a
very successful firm
which gave huge opportunity to hundreds
or thousands
of young people really who were trained
and developed in that way
and it also you know made an impact on
the corporate world as well we
we invented the idea of mergers and
acquisition strategy consulting was
completely different from anything that
anyone else had done
so one breakthrough achievement is the
fourth one the fifth one is make your
own trial which is
you know basically become bloody-minded
and work out a way of doing something
that goes off path
from everyone else and i describe how to
do that
the sixth one is to find and drive
your personal vehicle again one of the
discoveries in the book
is every one of these 20 people had some
kind of vehicle which in some ways
was sometimes it was a concept more
often it was an organization of some
sort of company
if it's in the business there or an
organization more broadly defined if it
isn't
the british state for example was a
vehicle
for uh margaret thatcher and for and for
winston churchill
together with a particularly eclectic
sense of
you know what they were trying to do the
whole point about a personal vehicle is
that
the paradox of the individual who
actually does manage to change the world
is that they can't do it on their own
but on the other hand
it doesn't get average it's not sort of
a committee deciding what to do
so someone like jeff bezos decides to
make internet retailing the thing which
he does
and the thing that you know the
everything everything store was the name
that they gave it originally
and no not just to be a successful
internet retailer within books but to be
a successful retailer
on the internet everywhere and to be
totally dominant in doing that
you know an incredibly ambitious thing
but in order to do that he needed to
have an organization which was totally
under his control
just the same way that lenin needed to
have
the bolsheviks you know a group of
people who were totally dedicated to
lenin not very many of them but a couple
of thousand
and that is necessary so that you
you overcome the inertia that society
and culture has so that an
individual can change things by being
very determined about it but they don't
have to do it all themselves
and the choice of the vehicle is is
terribly important
may i ask just before we move on is
there are there any particular
unusual or unorthodox examples that come
to mind
for both make your own trail and
find and drive your personal vehicle if
you could give perhaps one for
one for each yes i mean your
your own trail is is very much i think
walt disney land i don't mean i do
actually mean disneyland
the thing about walt disney is that he
couldn't decide what he wanted to do
initially he was a very good
actor when he was in high school and he
used to do double acts with a friend of
his
which were you know garnered a huge
amount of praise and then he
decided that he actually wanted to be an
artist but then
he narrowed that down to being a
cartoonist but
his firm which he started his studio
which he started
um in i think 1923
in los angeles was not very successful
for the first few years the big
breakthrough that
they came up with was mickey mouse
mickey mouse made all the difference
because they gave
a ridiculous story about a a mouse who
wanted to
woo a lady mouse by flying a plane
it was a really silly story but what
disney did was not only
sort of this film called plain crazy
which he turned into a very expensive
film which almost bankrupted him and his
brother and various other people
but he decided to give voices
to the characters from the screen which
which people had done before but never
with cartoons
so that was a sort of you know that was
his personal trial
in the 1940s he became disillusioned
with disney as a corporation it was a
very successful corporation by that
stage
but nevertheless he was disillusioned
with the fact that that
they were trying to take him away from
the studio he didn't have the sort of
excitement
of doing that he didn't really feel that
he was creating something new and so he
went into
you know to find his own personal trail
he actually spent quite a
bit of time with salvador dali and they
created a
a very surrealist movie which then the
board of
disney turned down and
walt disney was outraged by that and
he's and
he had to tell somebody that you know
they did not think that having the board
approve it was
anything other than a formality but the
board said no you
lost your marbles you know as peters and
watermen would say
later stick to the knitting except they
didn't use those words but that was
that was what they said that's what they
meant and so
walt disney decided to go off and do
something completely and utterly
different
which was invent disneyland until then
amusement parks had been the provinces
disney called them of uh
hard-faced men who
basically were thugs but what he wanted
to do was create
something which would be a monument to
the past
the present and the future of america
and all that was best in america now
you know the first time i ever went to
disneyland which was in 1969 i hated it
i thought it was too american and too
classic and all arrested
but it was a fantastic achievement in
the early 1950s
and hugely successful commercially again
he was making his own trail the board
again refused to invest in this
they refused to put up the capital for
all the um
exploratory work for all the imagination
that had to go into it
for building main street and the fire
station and
you know abraham lincoln and all the
rest of it they said no
we're not going to approve this walt and
walt said well screw you
in effect i will fund it myself and so
he
sold his houses he sort of you know took
second mortgages rather
on his houses he sold one of them and
took a second mortgage on the first
house
he found investors who would do this
and eventually at the last minute the
disney corporation
decided that they would come on board as
well when they saw it was
inevitable it was going to happen they
initially refused to let him use the
characters
snow white and donald duck and all the
rest of it they said no
if you do that we'll sue you so you know
if disneyland had failed which was
eminently possible disney would have
been ruined
and indeed uh the parent corporation
might have been in
some trouble one way or the other but
but but you know
that was finding his own trail because
he had this vision and he wanted to
pursue it and it was
nuts basically so that's an example of
making your own trail finding and
driving your own personal vehicle well i
think actually lenin is jolly good
example of that
it was the bolsheviks you know initially
the dissident revolutionaries
in exile around about 1900 etcetera
were dominated by people he later called
the
mensheviks by social revolutionists who
were not as extreme
and uncompromising as lenin
and there was a conference i think in
1903 or something like that
at which lenin deliberately antagonized
the other people
and said you know i want to have my own
party i'm going to split
the revolutionaries and they said don't
do that we've got you know there aren't
very many others
yeah please don't do that but he said no
i can demonstrate that if i have you
know a thousand people who are dedicated
to me
and to my way of doing things we can
have revolution in russia now
absurd because there are hundreds of
millions of people in the russian empire
and how could it be that a thousand
people
could actually change that and make
successful revolution
but lenin had an answer to that and it
was a very good answer
which was he said look russia is a very
backward country it's an autocracy it's
not like germany or france or britain
where
you know there are lots and lots of
different centers of power
all of the power is concentrated in the
czarist army
and the bureaucracy and there are only
about 2 000 people in russia who
actually control
things there are no independent centers
of
of uh social pluralism i'm sure he
didn't use that word but
but you know basically it's a very
top-down
state and if 2000 people
can rule russia
why not us
and that was his theory and actually
proved to be it proved to be absolutely
correct so his vehicle
was splitting the revolutionary movement
but having a group of people who are
absolutely dedicated to him and got shot
if they didn't
if they weren't so the vehicle is very
very important the vehicle doesn't
necessarily have to be very large but it
hugely augments
the power of the individual but it's not
a compromise you know the the vehicle
must be totally the vehicle in the same
way that bailing company was bill bain's
vehicle you know you stepped out of line
with bill bain
you didn't get shot but you certainly
got fired and and so on and so forth
boston consulting group was bruce
henderson's vehicle he did it a
different way
it was you know more let a thousand
flowers bloom
but nevertheless unless you were
interested in
developing the concepts which was
bruce's thing then
uh you weren't going to succeed and he
got people who are very good at doing
that
can i move on to the next three i'm
sorry i'm probably taking too much time
oh no that's that's totally fine that's
why this this conversation is long form
so let's move on to the next one
okay the seventh one is thrive on
setbacks and this
doesn't sound terribly original but it
is terribly important
you remember that nicholas nassim talab
wrote a book called anti-fragile which i
think is probably his best book
and the thesis behind that as you know
is
resilience is not the point you actually
have to like setbacks
and the reason that setbacks can be very
helpful is
is two reasons one is they give you
feedback and might tell you that you're
off
you know you're on the wrong path and
the other thing is
is that either you're wrong and wrong
path or you've got the wrong tactics and
it's quite important to distinguish
between those two
or that in fact the
fact that you've been unsuccessful in a
big way
means that you're going to be very
successful in a big way it's
quite difficult to describe i i also
think about winston churchill and his
wonderful failures he went away from
those failures obviously a bit depressed
at times he went
did something completely different for a
time uh getting out of politics after he
ruined the gallipoli campaign the
dardanelles campaign in
1915 and sent you know
several thousand people to their deaths
but from a hair brain scheme that he
invented and he got out of politics for
time he joined the regular army and he
went to the
um he went to the western front in in
1929 he was on the verge of bankruptcy
as a result of having
invested heavily in stocks in 1928 and
when
crash came along wall street crash he
was almost
bankrupt he decided to and also he was
very unpopular with his
fellow conservative leaders at that time
because he'd made a number of mistakes
in 1925 and going on to the gold
standard for britain and in antagonizing
the miners leading to the general strike
of 1926 and
alienating the whole of the organized
labor movement
so he was unpopular with his party he
was on the verge of bankruptcy he went
off and did a huge lecture tour of
america which was very successful
and and then he got run over on fifth
avenue by car
and suffered some quite serious injuries
but battered and bruised he got up and
did it again and you can see from what
he writes
that he thinks what's happening to him
is terribly important
and most people would say no this is a
semi-comical drunk who's
basically had a series of failures but
you know winston churchill didn't see it
that way it's very very interesting the
psychology of not being resilient but
actually really liking
photos because they they make you seem
important in some ways
and then the last two are acquiring
unique intuition which requires deep
knowledge and here i
think that i overlapped a little bit
with malcolm gladwell you know you
really do
the quality of intuition is a function
of the
degree of experience that you've had in
a very narrow field
but also your willingness to take notice
of intuition which some people do and
some people don't
and the last of them is distort reality
which is uh steve jobs
phrase of course based on star trek
but what distort reality
means is refusing to accept current
reality and redefining
a way of of making that different and
convincing your followers in particular
that
you know how to get around or distort
reality convincing them that you have a
reality distortion field
it works it's just amazing and and bruce
henderson did that bill bain does it all
the other people in the book had got
a way of of uh overcoming what was the
incredulity
of other people that they could actually
really change the world in a major way
i would love to make a few observations
based on a number of things you shared
and also
i'm going to follow that by asking you
for an example
of acquiring unique intuition because
this is of great interest to me but
i want to mention one a piece of trivia
for people that ties into a name that
came up several times
jeff bezos thriving on setbacks although
he didn't come up
in that particular landmark description
if you go to relentless.com it will
forward to where
to amazon.com so relentless.com
one of the first domain names uh pointed
to that website and what what strikes me
is that many of these landmarks
are reinforcing for
one another right so you have let's just
say self-belief olympian expectations
and i'm going to group them in a very
deliberate way self-belief olympian
expectations
one breakthrough achievement make your
own trail find and drive a personal
vehicle thrive on setbacks
and let's take distort reality because
i'm not yet
familiar enough with the acquire unique
intuition but all of those
to some degree seem to be enormously
enabled when you have
a longer term vision
and horizon in mind than your possible
competition so you
if you look at jeff bezos right he is
one of the few examples
of chief executive officers who have
been given a pass by wall street i mean
he's he's convinced his investors if you
go back and read his annual letters
which i encourage everyone to do you can
find a pdf of all past amazon annual
letters
there was always an emphasis on a long
term time horizon longer term than a
quarter
longer term than a year always longer
term bob iger at disney was another
great example of this
tobi lutky of shopify is another
incredible example of this and it just
strikes me that that this longer term
vision and time horizon enables a lot of
these and without that
if you are in any sense feeling
compelled to rush
that you disable uh some of these
landmarks up so that that's just
something that came to mind as you were
describing
i couldn't agree more i mean that's
absolutely true you need a long time
horizon you need to expect that you're
going to have massive impact
but it might take a very long time but
you need to be sure about what you're
trying to do
and you need to be sure that you'll get
there but you know
time is kind of you know there's lots of
time yeah
so acquiring unique intuition uh could
you perhaps give us an an example of
that that you like and
if there's one outside of steve jobs
that'd be great but you could use steve
jobs
if you like i think jobs is great
illustration of that but
but i'll take nelson mandela as my
example on this
nelson mandela was a leading member of
the anc
who got uh caught and convicted and sent
off to
prison total of i think 19 years in
prison a life sentence actually
uh he was quite lucky to escape the
noose and we were very lucky that he did
he was on uh this
island called robin island which i
visited off
cape town it's you know it's a short
boat ride away from cape town maybe half
an hour
at most but it's a world away and it's a
nasty horrible stark it's basically uh
it's a scrapyard essentially i mean it's
got it's got rocks
a lot of rocks and that's it i visited
the cell in which
he he'd been um incarcerated and it's so
small you wonder how
he could possibly have kept his
self-respect but
during that period of time something
very interesting happened
the leaders of south africa
including pw bother who was reckoned to
be the great crocodile sort of you know
very very
hostile to change actually realized that
they'd painted themselves into a corner
and that they didn't want to have
the possibility of um bloody revolution
and being driven into the sea as they as
they saw it
by the population of south africa
and the whites were you know maybe five
million people against
50 million plus who were blacks broadly
defined
and the anc were ratcheting up violence
and the anc were controlled by all of
the tambo in lusaka
some distance away and here was this
nelson mandela guy and he was
when he was in prison on robbin island
some
interesting things happened one is that
he acquired the charisma
of the sort of you know prison hero uh
so that within the anc he was viewed as
the natural leader
another interesting thing which has
happened was that there were various
outside forces including the british
commonwealth
that in the 1980s sent people
to robben island to talk to mandela
and try and see whether you know there
was any route forward there because they
couldn't speak to the
guys in exile in lusaka or wherever they
were
um and those guys were totally
uncompromising and
were trying to cause civil war and they
wouldn't have got anywhere
and so there were a group of people who
who went there was a group from the
commonwealth
it's called the eminent persons group
very
self-deprecating and these eminent
people went and
and of course they talked to nelson
mandela because he was the yeah
he was recognized to be almost the shop
steward of the prisoners
um and he'd formed a university there
where they
you know basically develop knowledge of
this that and the other
and somehow
nelson got the intuition that these
people actually wanted a deal
they didn't want this to be continued
forever
and they were willing to compromise in
some way that the hardline nationalists
who were nasty horrible races would
do apartheid and they shot people and
they were extremely unpleasant there's
no doubt about it
these people actually wanted a solution
and he was the first person to realize
that
the anc had always said and nelson
mandela had always said we will not
compromise
but when he met some of these people
from the commonwealth and when he met
later some of the senior ministers
from the government of the nationalist
party the ruling party
he suddenly realized that a deal was
possible
and he said to them you know
if you really want to deal you're going
to have to have one person one vote and
they said we couldn't possibly have that
democracy no we don't want democracy
there are more blacks than whites we
can't possibly do that
um but you know nelson stuck to that
and eventually he formed personal
relationships
with the head of the secret service the
secret police as it were
with the uh minister who was responsible
for
um justice with the minister who was
responsible for state security
including the prisons and eventually
with pw
botha himself and
it was all based on this intuition that
perhaps they could reach a deal
and nobody else had that intuition
nobody but nelson mandela
actually thought it was worthwhile
pursuing talks with those people and
it took five years but in the end
his intuition won out and the result was
that
instead of having a war and
you know bloody bloodshed going on and
possible revolution
and the only question for people really
was whether that be five years or 50
years before
you know that whites would be thrown out
and massacred
instead of that you might have a
transition to black majority rule
and that that could be done in a
controlled way
where f w d clerk who succeeded bowser
uh would be the vice president and
effectively the mentor
of um nelson mandela i've talked
personally
to fw to clerk about these days for some
reason i had an opportunity to do that
and you know he was quite clear about it
if it had not have been for mandela and
of course he said himself
you know the odds against this would be
a thousand it was just based
on this intuition that there might be a
solution where everyone else thought
there wouldn't be a solution
and he would not have known that but for
being
in prison on robin island for 17 years
and meeting all these people and
gradually being able to size them up
including the heads of the uh prison who
were varied in quality from
unpleasant to brutal but nevertheless
you know
he knew he worked out that the way the
wind was growing
and nobody else did as i was working in
south africa at the time
and we never thought that there was a
possibility of any solution nobody that
i talked to did
but nelson mandela had a different
intuition i described that in the book
and it's very very
it's very heartwarming there's some
horrible stories in the book but it's
very heartwarming
you know intuition is hugely important
thank you for
sharing that example i think it's it's a
wonderful place to start to wrap up this
round one we may have to
we may have to do a round two on the
podcast if you have the endurance
sometime
i would like i would love to but richard
i want to ensure that people know where
they can find you
of course on on twitter they can find
you at richard
8020 8020 richard koch.net
you've written many books including many
books that have influenced
me like the 80 20 principle you have the
star principle which which we've
we've mentioned a number of times and
your newest book is
unreasonable success and how to achieve
it
i have just one more question for you
and then certainly i'm open to any
closing comments or anything else that
you would like to share if i've omitted
anything certainly or if there's just
anything in addition that you'd like to
put forth
and i'll start this question with a
quote as prelude
and this is from an interview that i
found
with you and it relates to new year's
resolutions this is a quote
which you can of course feel free to
correct but this is attributed to you
once a year rather than doing new year's
resolutions i ask the same question
what did i do that meant the most to me
and my family and friends
and sometimes strangers too and what
could i do in the next year
more of the same is not a bad answer but
something fresh too
so this really struck me as an impactful
question and good questions are
impactful
and so a is this something that you
do and and might recommend and number
two are there any
other questions you might
suggest listeners consider
or ponder let gestate on their minds
yes it is true and i think it's right
the question i would ask is one again
from from the book which is
in your whole life what is your
breakthrough achievement going to be
if you want to change the world how do
you want to change the world
and ponder that maybe on new year's eve
maybe any other time there's plenty of
time to work it out
but do you really want to have a major
impact on the world if you do
what that's really my question is a
question i ask myself as well i mean my
own
ambition is to is to have many more
creative completely unreasonably
successful people
and the thing i'm toying with
which i don't know if you think is a
good idea or not but
but is offering to work with a number of
people who
have already been reasonably successful
but have not been unreasonably
successful
and take them through the process and
see whether we can generate
some unreasonable success from a lot of
people
and to cascade that down and train other
people to do that because i think this
methodology is
robust and i think it could make a huge
difference to the world and i'd like to
see whether
i can demonstrate that in practice
through a few pilot studies so that's my
personal ambition i love that i think
you should definitely
test it and it could be a spectacular
failure or spectacular success but
nothing ventured nothing gained and you
do like to bet
so i figure this is is one good
opportunity to do that
and having some experience with
vetting i'm not volunteering myself but
i would say run a competition
or or have applications that are vetted
and can be vetted in some very simple
ways that you're not overwhelmed
and pick a handful of finalists to take
through that process and
what what i'll suggest just as a
placeholder is that people follow you
on twitter richard 80 208020
and if you decide to do this you can you
can share that
on on twitter and that can be at least a
possible starting point so that
people are are alert that this is a
possibility
and what a pleasure it's been richard i
feel like
i know you in the same way that perhaps
some people
i meet who listen to the podcast feel
like they know me but it's been through
your written words
that i have have come to admire
and use quite frankly with great effect
much of your thinking so i i thank you
very much for taking the time today this
has been an incredible
incredible pleasure and i hope it's not
the last
indeed tim thank you very much indeed i
i reciprocate
much more much more pleasure for me i'm
sure it really is great anyway thank you
very much indeed
and i look forward to talking to you
again at some stage maybe
maybe a bit a bit more frequently that'd
be wonderful
well the feeling is is definitely mutual
and to those
listening i will have show notes for
everything we've discussed including
all of the books all of the resources
including the
most recent work from richard which is
unreasonable success and how to achieve
it
at tim dot blog forward slash podcast
we'll have links to all the names
everything you can imagine so please do
check that out if you'd like to indulge
in more exploration
and until next time as always thank you
for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by athletic greens
i get asked all the time what i would
take if i could only take one supplement
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
i view it as my all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in 2010 in the
four-hour body and i did not get paid to
do so
i've used it ever since developed from a
complex blend of 75
vitamins minerals and whole food source
ingredients athletic greens is a greens
powder engineered to help fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet
so i always try to do things through
whole foods but this covers my bases
right now athletic greens is offering
you their vitamin d3 k2 liquid formula
free with your first purchase
two vital nutrients for a strong immune
system and strong bones so simply visit
athleticgreens.com
tim to claim this special offer today
and receive the free
d3k2 bundle with your first purchase
that's up to a one year supply of
vitamin d is added value when you try
their delicious and comprehensive
all-in-one daily greens product
again that's athleticgreens.com tim
this episode is brought to you by fiori
clothing spelled v-u-o-r-i
biore i've been wearing fiori at least
one
item per day for the last few months and
you can use it for everything it's
performance apparel
but it can be used for working out it
can be used for
going out to dinner at least in my case
i feel very comfortable with it
super comfortable super stylish and i
just want to read
something that one of my employees said
she is an athlete
she is quite technical although she
would never say that i asked her if she
had ever
used or heard of biore and this was her
response
i do love their stuff been using them
for about a year i think i found them at
rei first for my partner
t-shirts that are super soft and somehow
last as he's hard on stuff and then i
got into the super soft cotton yoga
pants and jogger
sweatpants i live in them and they too
have lasted they're stylish enough i can
wear them out and about
the material is just super soft and
durable i just got their clementine
running shorts for summer and love them
the brand seems pretty popular
constantly sold out in closing and i'm
abbreviating here but in closing
with the exception of when i need
technical outdoor gear they're the only
brand i bought in the last
year or so for yoga running loungewear
that lasts and
that i think look good also i like the
discrete logo
so that gives you some idea that was not
intended for the sponsor read uh that
was just
her response via text fiori again
spelled b-u-o-r-i
is designed for maximum comfort and
versatility you can wear it running
you can wear their stuff training doing
yoga lounging
weekend errands or in my case again
going out to dinner it really doesn't
matter what you're doing
their clothing is so comfortable and
looks so good and it's it's
non-offensive you don't have a huge
brand logo in your face you'll just want
to be in them all the time and my
girlfriend and i have been wearing them
for the last few months they're men's
core short kore
the most comfortable lined athletic
short is your one short for every sport
i've been using it for kettlebell swings
for
runs you name it the banks short this is
their go to land
to see short is the ultimate versatility
it's made from recycled plastic bottles
and what i'm wearing right now
which i had to pick one to recommend to
folks out there or at least men out
there is the ponto performance
pant and you'll find these at the link
i'm going to give you guys
you can check out what i'm talking about
but i'm wearing them right now
they're thin performance sweat pants but
that doesn't do them justice so you
gotta check it out ponto ponto
performance pant
for you ladies the women's performance
jogger is the softest jogger you'll ever
own
fiori isn't just an investment in your
clothing it's an investment in your
happiness and for you my dear listeners
they're offering 20
off your first purchase so get yourself
some of the most comfortable and
versatile clothing on the planet
it's super popular a lot of my friends
have now noticed are wearing this
and so am i biore clothing dot com
forward slash tim that's
b u o r i clothing dot com
slash tim not only will you receive 20
off your first purchase
but you'll also enjoy free shipping on
any u.s orders over 75 dollars
and free returns so check it out
theoryclothing.com
tim that's v-u-o-r-i clothing dot com
tim and discover the versatility of
fiori clothing